This episode is brought to you by the Lloyd's 5K House Deposit, and this is something that was last seen in 1996. Yeah, so the 1990s looks now like a lost golden age of prosperity and positivity, doesn't it? Think of the sort of the advent of the Blair administration in 1997, all the enthusiasm and excitement that surrounded that, the economic growth at the time, the technological developments, the sort of sense of an endless golden summer where everybody is listening to Blair and Oasis and looking forward to, to buying their first houses, and that, of course, takes us to mortgages. Now, the good news is that in a nod to the 1990s, Lloyds are offering 5K deposit mortgages to first-time buyers. So search 5K first-time buyer. 1996 average first-time buyer deposits are based on ONS data. Subject to status, your home may be repossessed if you don't keep up repayments and conditions apply.
本期节目由劳埃德银行（Lloyd's）5000英镑房屋首付贷款赞助播出，这项服务上一次出现还是在1996年。没错，现在的20世纪90年代看起来就像是一个失落的繁荣与积极向上的黄金时代，不是吗？想想1997年布莱尔政府上台时的那种热情与兴奋，当时的经济增长、技术发展，以及那种仿佛无尽的黄金之夏的感觉——每个人都在听着布莱尔和绿洲乐队（Oasis）的歌，期待着购买他们的第一套房子，而这自然就让我们想到了抵押贷款。好消息是，为了向90年代致敬，劳埃德银行为首次购房者提供了5000英镑首付的抵押贷款。所以，请搜索“5K first-time buyer”。1996年首次购房者的平均首付额基于英国国家统计局（ONS）的数据。需视个人信用状况而定，如果您未能按时还款，您的房屋可能会被收回，且适用相关条款。
This episode is sponsored by Ancestry. The First World War doesn't just survive in monuments and history books. It survives in smaller things too. Forms, ledgers, service numbers and addresses. Those are the details that can make family history feel less distant. A surname you recognise, a regiment, the detail that brings a family story, into focus. More than 5 million men served in the British Armed Forces during the First World War. And for many British families, that war is just a few generations away. July marks the 110th anniversary of the Battle of the Somme.
本期节目由Ancestry赞助。第一次世界大战不仅仅存在于纪念碑和历史书中，它也存在于更细微的事物中。表格、账簿、服役编号和地址，这些细节能让家族史显得不再那么遥远。一个你熟悉的姓氏、一个军团，这些细节让家族故事变得清晰可见。第一次世界大战期间，有超过500万名男子在英国武装部队服役。对于许多英国家庭来说，那场战争距离现在不过几代人的时间。七月是索姆河战役爆发110周年。
It is a time not just to look at the scale of that story, but the individual lives behind it. Visit Ancestry.com.uk. and search First World War military records to discover your family's role in the First World War. We hold these truths to be self-evident that all men are created equal, that they're endowed by their creator with certain inalienable rights, that among these are life, liberty, and the pursuit of happiness. that to secure these rights, governments are instituted among men, deriving their just powers from the consent of the governed. That whenever any form of government becomes destructive of these ends, it's the right of the people to alter or to abolish it,
现在不仅是审视那段历史规模的时候，更是关注其背后一个个鲜活生命的时候。访问Ancestry.com.uk并搜索“第一次世界大战军事记录”，探索您的家族在第一次世界大战中的角色。我们认为这些真理是不言而喻的：人人生而平等，造物主赋予他们若干不可剥夺的权利，其中包括生命权、自由权和追求幸福的权利。为了保障这些权利，人类才建立政府，而政府的正当权力，是经由被治理者的同意而产生的。当任何形式的政府对这些目标具有破坏作用时，人民便有权改变或废除它，
and to institute new government, laying its foundation on such principles and organising its powers in such form, as to them shall seem most likely to affect their safety and happiness. So that was the Declaration of Independence. Now, at those words, our American listeners, many of them will have started crying with pride and joy, because this is, of course, the most celebrated document in all American history. Americans learn in school, though they're told in school, that it's one of the great masterpieces of English prose.
并建立新的政府，其基础原则及组织权力的形式，应以人民认为最能实现其安全和幸福为准。以上就是《独立宣言》的内容。听到这些话，我们的美国听众中会有许多人因自豪和喜悦而落泪，因为这当然是美国历史上最受推崇的文件。美国学生在学校里学习，或者说被告知，这是英语散文中最伟大的杰作之一。
they regarded as a statement of principles that's a symbol of the country and a testament to the power of the American dream, even though, of course, as Samuel Johnson pointed out at the time, many of the people who were endorsing the Declaration of Independence themselves owned other human beings. But of course, we won't go into that, Tom, just yet. So this is one of the landmark documents in all human history. We have been marking its 250th anniversary and the anniversary of the tax revolt for which it was a press release, by looking at the lives of four of the most notable founding fathers. And today, we turn our attention to the man who wrote those words. And that man is, of course, Thomas Jefferson. It is. And that is the document for which he is
他们将其视为一项原则声明，是国家的一种象征，也是美国梦力量的证明，尽管正如塞缪尔·约翰逊当时所指出的那样，许多签署《独立宣言》的人自己就拥有奴隶。但当然，汤姆，我们暂时先不谈这个。所以，这是人类历史上具有里程碑意义的文件之一。我们一直在纪念它发表250周年，以及作为其发布背景的抗税运动，我们通过回顾四位最著名的开国元勋的生平来纪念。今天，我们将目光转向撰写这些文字的人，那个人当然就是托马斯·杰斐逊。确实如此。而这正是他最广为人知的
best known, a document which, as you said, is one of the very few documents to have changed history. But I think his status as the author of the Declaration of Independence kind of very best. barely scratches the surface of his remarkable range of achievements. So you can see from the Declaration itself, which he wrote when he was only 33, that this is a man of remarkable intellectual gifts. Kenneth Clark in Civilization, the landmark BBC series, in the episode on The Revolutionary Era, he described Jefferson as the emblematic genius of the age. he described him as a universal man.
文件，正如你所说，这是极少数改变了历史的文件之一。但我认为，他作为《独立宣言》作者的身份，几乎无法涵盖他非凡成就的广度。从他33岁时写下的《独立宣言》本身就可以看出，这是一个拥有非凡智力天赋的人。肯尼斯·克拉克在BBC的里程碑式系列纪录片《文明》中，在关于“革命时代”的那一集中，将杰斐逊描述为那个时代的标志性天才，称他为“全才”。
And when you look at the range of Jefferson's accomplishments, you can see what Clark was on about. So Jefferson was a scholar who's learning embraced classical scholarship. He was a brilliant classical scholar. He was fascinated in history and natural history, in agriculture, in philosophy, in architecture. Very enthusiastic architect. Music, philosophy, law, meteorology, palae, and so, I mean, basically, there is no limit to the range of his interests. He knew Latin, he knew Greek, he knew Italian, he knew French, he knew Spanish. He was also a very keen gardener.
当你审视杰斐逊的成就范围时，你就能明白克拉克所指的含义。杰斐逊是一位学者，他的学识涵盖了古典学术。他是一位杰出的古典学者。他痴迷于历史、自然史、农业、哲学和建筑学。他是一位非常热情的建筑师。音乐、哲学、法律、气象学、古生物学等等，我的意思是，他的兴趣范围基本上没有限制。他懂拉丁语、希腊语、意大利语、法语和西班牙语。他也是一位非常热衷的园艺家。
He was a pioneer in the culture of the tomato. Wow. Which at this time, Americans viewed the tomato with great suspicion. And as far as I know, he's the only founding father to have written down a recipe for ice cream. Surely Aaron Burr had an excellent ice cream recipe. Now, this mention of ice cream, may prompt listeners who've heard our episode on George Washington. Yeah. To wonder what Jefferson's teeth were like. American teeth, poor. And Dominic, you've been using the terrible state of his teeth as a bit of a metaphor, haven't you? Yeah.
他是番茄种植的先驱。哇。而在当时，美国人对番茄持有极大的怀疑态度。据我所知，他是唯一一位写下冰淇淋配方的开国元勋。难道阿龙·伯尔就没有出色的冰淇淋配方吗？现在，提到冰淇淋可能会让听过我们乔治·华盛顿那一集的听众感到好奇，杰斐逊的牙齿怎么样？美国人的牙齿很差。多米尼克，你一直把他的牙齿状况糟糕作为一种隐喻，不是吗？是的。
So it'll delight you to know that Jefferson's teeth are excellent. So even in old age, he could boast that his gnashes were in a superb condition. He'd only lost one tooth, he said, with the rest continuing sound. He had the teeth of a horse. No? And indeed, he resembled. He looked like a horse. Like a surplus horse, he had. no flesh is one of the comments on him. So he's a very lean, ranging man. Yeah, equine. Yes, a kind of aquiline as well, a kind of horse eagle, I guess you could get kind of a fusion. Right. And this is because, as well as being a devotee of ice cream, he's a very firm believer in a brisk fitness regime, which again is kind of very American, isn't it? In America, it seems to me, you're either
所以，很高兴告诉你，杰斐逊的牙齿非常好。即使到了晚年，他也能夸耀自己的牙齿状况极佳。他说他只掉了一颗牙，其余的都完好无损。他有一口马牙。不？事实上，他长得确实像。他看起来像匹马。像匹多余的马，有人评论说他“没有赘肉”。所以他是一个非常瘦削、高大的人。是的，马一样的。是的，还有点像鹰，我想你可以说是一种融合。对。这是因为，除了是冰淇淋的忠实拥护者外，他还是严格健身制度的坚定信徒，这又非常“美国”，不是吗？在我看来，在美国，你不是在
guzzling ice cream or you're obsessively fit. Jefferson is the embodiment of both. So he wrote to friend in 1786, if the body be feeble, the mind will not be strong. The sovereign invigorator of the body is exercise and of all the exercises walking is best. And he is not wrong. Do you know what, Tom? I know you're trying to rehabilitate Jefferson because, of course, in Britain and in much of the world, Jefferson is regarded as one of history's great villains. But so far, you're not doing a great job because he sounds awful. He sounds, I mean, he's, I hate him far more. You hate him more? All his fitness. It's just so performative. All right. This is so performative, wittering on about gardens, talking about meteorites, learning Italian.
狂吃冰淇淋，就是在疯狂健身。杰斐逊是这两者的化身。他在1786年写信给朋友说：“如果身体虚弱，头脑就不会强健。身体的至高活力源于运动，而在所有运动中，步行是最好的。”他说得没错。你知道吗，汤姆？我知道你正试图为杰斐逊平反，因为在英国和世界大部分地区，杰斐逊被视为历史上最伟大的恶棍之一。但到目前为止，你做得并不好，因为他听起来很糟糕。他听起来，我的意思是，我更讨厌他了。你更讨厌他？他所有的健身。这太做作了。好了。这太做作了，喋喋不休地谈论花园，谈论陨石，学习意大利语。
Come on. Pipe down and watch TV or something. Okay. Let's see if this makes him more appealing to you. Yeah. Because you do love a canny, a hard-nosed political operator. I do. I love it.
得了吧。闭嘴，去看电视什么的。好吧。让我们看看这是否能让他对你更有吸引力。因为你确实喜欢精明、强硬的政治操盘手。我确实喜欢。我喜欢。
And I think there is no one in American history who has more brilliantly combined the kind of deep learning that you despise with the various arts required to obtain, to maintain. to utilize power. So obviously he's massively consequential as the author of the Declaration of Independence, but he is also a key player, perhaps the key player in shaping the American Republic in the first decades of its existence. And if you think of every plum post that you could have as a politician in the early years of the American Republic, Jefferson holds it. So first of all, he is the ambassador to France. So he arrives there in 1718. in succession to Benjamin Franklin, who we did in a previous episode. And he, when he's in France, he becomes a massive Francophile.
我认为在美国历史上，没有人能比他更出色地将你所鄙视的那种深厚学识，与获取、维持和利用权力所需的各种手段结合起来。显然，作为《独立宣言》的作者，他影响巨大，但他也是塑造美国共和国最初几十年里的关键人物，或许是最关键的人物。如果你想到美国建国初期政治家能担任的每一个显赫职位，杰斐逊都担任过。首先，他是驻法大使。所以他在1718年到达那里，接替了我们在上一集中提到的本杰明·富兰克林。当他在法国时，他成了一个狂热的亲法派。
He thinks France is great. And I can see your face clouding at these. France is where he gets his recipe for ice cream. Yeah, fair. Okay. He, and he leaves in September 1789, by which point, of course, the French Revolution has kicked off. And Jefferson is a big fan of the French Revolution, and he sees it as a passing of the torch of liberty from America across the Atlantic to France. And he's a great pal of someone else you really admire, which is Lafayette.
他认为法国很棒。我能看到你听到这些时眉头紧锁。法国是他获得冰淇淋配方的地方。是的，有道理。好吧。他在1789年9月离开，那时法国大革命已经爆发。杰斐逊是法国大革命的忠实粉丝，他将其视为自由的火炬从美国跨越大西洋传向法国。而且他是你非常钦佩的另一个人的好朋友，那就是拉法耶特。
Lafayette and Jefferson have been absolute mates throughout the 1580s. And Jefferson advises Lafayette on the drafting of the rights of man and the citizen. And even when he gets back to America, and he discusses. others that enthusiasm there for the French Revolution is slightly muted by the tendency of the French Revolution to go around guillotining everyone. Jefferson still sticks up for the revolution. So he says we are not to expect to be translated from despotism into liberty in a feather bed. Problem for you this, Tom, because you're a big fan of Marion Twennett. So you have divided loyalties here. I evaluate everyone in their own terms, Dominic.
拉法耶特和杰斐逊在整个18世纪80年代都是绝对的好友。杰斐逊为拉法耶特起草《人权和公民权宣言》提供了建议。即使在他回到美国后，当他讨论时，对法国大革命的热情也因法国大革命到处处决人的倾向而略有减弱。杰斐逊仍然支持这场革命。他说：“我们不能指望在羽绒床上从专制被转化为自由。”这对你来说是个问题，汤姆，因为你是玛丽·安托瓦内特的忠实粉丝。所以你在这里有分歧的忠诚。我根据每个人自己的立场来评价他们，多米尼克。
Okay, fine. Well, I don't actually admire Marianne. I think she was, I mean, she was hopeless. And what was she thinking? Wow, you've changed. You've changed. She was good as a queen in Versailles. She was terrible as someone who had to negotiate with revolution. You're not wrong. That's my take on her.
好吧，没问题。其实我并不钦佩玛丽·安托瓦内特。我认为她，我的意思是，她无可救药。她在想什么？哇，你变了。你变了。她作为凡尔赛的王后表现不错，但作为需要与革命谈判的人，她表现得很糟糕。你没说错。这就是我对她的看法。
Whereas Jefferson is a man who can accommodate himself to changing political circumstances, which is what he does when he gets back to America, where Washington appoints him as America's first secretary of state. And so he takes that office up in 1790. And of course, this brings him into massive conflict with the hero of our previous episode, Alexander Hamilton. So Hamilton is in charge of finance. Jefferson is in charge of foreign affairs. And they are polar opposites.
而杰斐逊是一个能够适应不断变化的政治环境的人，这正是他回到美国后所做的，华盛顿任命他为美国第一任国务卿。于是他在1790年就任该职。当然，这使他与我们上一集的英雄亚历山大·汉密尔顿产生了巨大的冲突。汉密尔顿负责财政，杰斐逊负责外交。他们是截然相反的。
So as we heard in our previous episode, Hamilton, he's a federalist. He thinks that there should be a strong centre. Banks, yeah. He loves a bank. He loves a banker. He loves the national debt. He loves Britain. He hates anarchy.
正如我们在上一集中听到的，汉密尔顿是联邦党人。他认为应该有一个强大的中央政府。银行，是的。他热爱银行。他热爱银行家。他热爱国债。他热爱英国。他痛恨无政府状态。
These are his principles. Jefferson is almost the polar opposite. So he sees a strong federal state as an enemy of the liberty of the individual states. He loves a farmer, not a banker. He sees bankers as vampires sucking out the blood of hardworking, noble American farmers. He doesn't approve of national debts. He loves France, as we heard. and his great guiding principle is his hatred of tyranny.
这些是他的原则。杰斐逊几乎是截然相反的。他将强大的联邦政府视为各州个人自由的敌人。他热爱农民，而不是银行家。他将银行家视为吸食勤劳、高尚的美国农民血液的吸血鬼。他不赞成国债。他热爱法国，正如我们所听到的。他伟大的指导原则是他对暴政的仇恨。
And so both men, Hamilton and Jefferson, see the other one, you know, not just as a political opponent, but pretty much as a kind of threat to the liberty of the infant American republic. Yeah. And Jefferson's own take on their relationship in Washington's cabinet is that they were daily pitted in the cabinet like two cocks. Listeners can make of that one what they will. And there is so much cockfighting going on between them. in the end Jefferson resigns he resigns in 1793 because he recognises that the disagreements between them can't be reconciled within the one government so by now we have as we were talking about last time the beginnings of the first party system so Jefferson is effectively the standard bearer
所以汉密尔顿和杰斐逊两人都将对方视为，你知道，不仅是政治对手，几乎是威胁到初生美国共和国自由的一种威胁。是的。杰斐逊对自己与华盛顿内阁中两人关系的看法是，他们每天在内阁里像两只斗鸡一样针锋相对。听众们可以随心所欲地理解这一点。他们之间发生了太多的“斗鸡”事件。最终杰斐逊辞职了，他在1793年辞职，因为他认识到他们之间的分歧无法在一个政府内调和。所以现在，正如我们上次谈到的，我们有了第一党制的开端，所以杰斐逊实际上是旗手，
isn't he of the America's first opposition party yes so the democratic republicans is they're called in opposition to hamilton's federalists yeah and throughout this period Washington as you said in the previous episode tries to stay above the fray in a kind of Olympian manner, but it is obvious that throughout his presidency, a two-party system is kind of evolving. And that isn't something that the Constitution had ever envisaged. That was never kind of part of the plan. And on one side, we have the Federalists, so Hamilton, but also John Adams, an old friend of Jefferson's. Jefferson had hung out in France with John Adams and his remarkable wife, Abigail. So John Adams, Boston lawyer.
不是吗？美国第一个反对党的旗手。是的，也就是民主共和党，正如他们被称为的那样，以对抗汉密尔顿的联邦党人。是的，在这一时期，正如你在上一集中所说，华盛顿试图以一种奥林匹亚式的方式置身事外，但很明显，在他的整个总统任期内，两党制正在演变。这并不是宪法所预想的。这从来不是计划的一部分。一方面，我们有联邦党人，也就是汉密尔顿，还有约翰·亚当斯，杰斐逊的老朋友。杰斐逊曾与约翰·亚当斯和他非凡的妻子阿比盖尔在法国共度时光。所以约翰·亚当斯，波士顿律师。
this fantastically smart wife, and he ends up as Washington's vice president. And then on the other, we have effectively the first kind of mass popular party in history, really. And Jefferson stands at its head. But I guess the real creator of it, the guy who kind of operates the nuts and bolts, is James Madison. Yeah. So key figure in drafting the Constitution will be president when our brave boys burn the White House and send Dolly Madison, his wife, fleeing. And Madison is busy kind of constructing the mechanics of a party system.
这位极其聪明的妻子，他最终成为了华盛顿的副总统。另一方面，我们实际上拥有了历史上第一个大众政党。而杰斐逊站在它的领导位置。但我猜真正的创造者，那个负责具体运作的人，是詹姆斯·麦迪逊。是的。他是起草宪法的关键人物，当我们的勇敢小伙子们烧毁白宫并让他的妻子多莉·麦迪逊逃离时，他将是总统。麦迪逊正忙于构建政党制度的机制。
And Jefferson plays the role of the enlightened philosopher. So again, a bit like Washington, looking as though he's above the fray, but actually he isn't at all. And I think you could say that Madison and Jefferson's partnership is easily the most effective political partnership in early American history. Surely. Yeah. I mean, it's incredibly creative. And so this puts Jefferson in a very good position in 1796, when Washington was.
而杰斐逊扮演了开明哲学家的角色。所以，再次像华盛顿一样，看起来好像置身事外，但实际上他根本不是。我认为你可以说麦迪逊和杰斐逊的伙伴关系是美国早期历史上最有效的政治伙伴关系。当然。是的。我的意思是，它非常有创造力。这使得杰斐逊在1796年处于一个非常有利的位置，当时华盛顿
stands down and it's clear there's going to be another president. And so he is running effectively against John Adams. I mean, there are other other contenders as well. And it is Adams who is elected. Jefferson comes second. And by the conventions of the time, that means that he automatically becomes vice president. Adams has won, but it's not by a massive amount. So Adams has had 71 votes to Jefferson 68. And Jefferson is pretty chuffed by this. So he he wrote that he sort of his tally is the index of the place I hold in the esteem of my fellow citizens. And he's not wrong. Jefferson is clearly a potential election winner. This has not dashed his hopes of becoming president. He's in poll position probably to run in the next election. But having said that,
卸任了，很明显会有另一位总统。所以他实际上是在与约翰·亚当斯竞争。我的意思是，还有其他竞争者。最终当选的是亚当斯。杰斐逊名列第二。按照当时的惯例，这意味着他自动成为副总统。亚当斯赢了，但优势并不大。亚当斯获得了71票，杰斐逊获得了68票。杰斐逊对此感到非常高兴。他写道，他的票数是他“在同胞心目中所占地位的指标”。他没说错。杰斐逊显然是一个潜在的选举赢家。这并没有打消他成为总统的希望。他可能处于下一次选举的领先位置。但话虽如此，
the four years that he spends as vice president are very frustrating for him. Because effectively, as John Adams himself had found, being vice president is simply, you have nothing to do. It was a guy called John Nance Garner who said it's not worth a pitcher of warm piss. Yes. So I think this, Jefferson wouldn't put it quite like that. Yeah. Put it in slightly more Ciceronian tones. But I think that's his perspective.
他担任副总统的四年对他来说非常令人沮丧。因为实际上，正如约翰·亚当斯本人所发现的那样，担任副总统简直就是无事可做。有个叫约翰·南斯·加纳的人说，这“不值一壶温尿”。是的。所以我认为，杰斐逊不会那样说。是的，会用稍微更西塞罗式的语气。但我认为这就是他的观点。
But an additional problem, he doesn't just feel impotent. He feels aggravated by Adams' policies. So he strongly disagrees with a lot of the policies that his old friend John Adams is pursuing. And in fact, he ends up convinced that Adams' administration is threatening the end of American liberty, he sees Adams and Hamilton as kind of monarchical figures, people who want to reimpose the kind of British constitution by the back door. And so unsurprisingly, his kind of old friendship with John and Abigail Adams completely crashes at tanks. I mean, this is one of the things obviously we talked about last time, the extent to which the founding fathers,
但还有一个额外的问题，他不仅感到无能为力，还对亚当斯的政策感到愤怒。他强烈反对他的老朋友约翰·亚当斯正在推行的许多政策。事实上，他最终确信亚当斯的政府正在威胁美国自由的终结，他将亚当斯和汉密尔顿视为某种君主制人物，那些想要通过后门重新强加英国宪法的人。所以不出所料，他与约翰和阿比盖尔·亚当斯的旧友谊彻底破裂了。我的意思是，这是我们上次谈到的事情之一，开国元勋们在多大程度上，
as they call, they're kind of splintered by factionalism. And they all come to believe, don't they? Because they've basically spent far too much time reading, doing Latin. They come to believe that, you know, like the Roman Republic, their system is doomed to atrophy into despotism. Yeah. And that sort of shadow hangs over the whole story. There's a lot of Roman cosplaying. Yeah. And that means that if you're casting yourself as the hero in a Roman drama,
正如他们所说，他们被派系主义分裂了。他们都开始相信，不是吗？因为他们基本上花了太多时间阅读、研究拉丁语。他们开始相信，就像罗马共和国一样，他们的制度注定会萎缩成专制。是的。那种阴影笼罩着整个故事。有很多罗马式的角色扮演。是的。这意味着如果你把自己塑造成罗马戏剧中的英雄，
there are all kinds of villains, as we will see. But Jefferson sits it out. He doesn't resign. He doesn't flounce off in a half because the whole way through he's playing this kind of waiting game. He has his eyes fixed on the big prize, which is the presidency. And to win it, of course, he will have to depose John Adams, who is his old friend, sitting president. And so this is the first presidential rematch in American history.
正如我们将看到的，会有各种各样的恶棍。但杰斐逊坚持了下来。他没有辞职。他没有因为半途而废而愤然离去，因为他一直在玩这种等待游戏。他的目光紧盯着大奖，那就是总统职位。为了赢得它，他当然必须罢免约翰·亚当斯，那是他的老朋友，现任总统。所以这是美国历史上第一次总统竞选重赛。
And when the campaign begins all along, Jefferson is the slight but definite favorite. Yeah. And Adams meets with Jefferson in Philadelphia before the election has actually been announced. And already, Adams is basically saying, oh, I've lost. their conversation is recorded as thus. Adams, well, I understand that you are to beat me in this contest and I will only say that I will be as faithful a subject as any you will have. Jefferson, Mr. Adams, this is no personal contest between you and me.
当竞选开始时，杰斐逊一直是微弱但明确的领先者。是的。在选举正式宣布之前，亚当斯在费城会见了杰斐逊。亚当斯基本上已经在说，哦，我输了。他们的谈话记录如下：亚当斯：“好吧，我明白你将在这次竞争中击败我，我只想说，我将成为你所拥有的最忠诚的臣民。”杰斐逊：“亚当斯先生，这不是你我之间的个人竞争。”
So it's very stirring, it's very founding fathers, it's the kind of thing that you might get to translate in a passage of Latin prose. You know, it's, again, they're absolutely cosplaying here. But actually, the presidential contest, the second one, between Jefferson and, Adams, it's much more Trump against Biden. Right. Than it is, something from the early years of the Roman Republic. Because of the bitterness, the sheer depths of the bitterness between federalists and
所以这非常感人，非常有开国元勋的风范，这是你在翻译一段拉丁散文时可能会遇到的那种话。你知道，他们在这里绝对是在进行角色扮演。但实际上，杰斐逊和亚当斯之间的第二次总统竞选，更像是特朗普对阵拜登。对，而不是罗马共和国早期的某种东西。因为联邦党人和
democratic Republicans, exactly. It's a party contest as well. So it's completely fortuporative. And Jefferson's opponents, so Adams, Hamilton, all of that crew, they go all in trying to blacken Jefferson's name. They accuse him of being an atheist, of being a Jacques. So the kind of person who, if he wins, will set about guillotining his opponents. You know, they are casting Jefferson as a threat to the Republic.
民主共和党人之间那种苦涩的深度，完全是党派竞争。所以这完全是破坏性的。杰斐逊的对手，也就是亚当斯、汉密尔顿那一伙人，他们全力以赴试图抹黑杰斐逊的名字。他们指责他是无神论者，是雅各宾派。所以那种如果他赢了，就会开始处决对手的人。你知道，他们把杰斐逊塑造成对共和国的威胁。
But Jefferson is going in equally hard. You know, it says Adams is a kind of crypto monarchist. He's a British stooge. He wants to reintroduce monarchical flummery and all this kind of thing. And Jefferson's campaign works. And so already by December, he's confident that he has the election in the bag. but there is a twist and Dominic you hinted at this twist in the previous episode. So listeners may recall that in the previous election, Adams and Jefferson had run on individual
但杰斐逊也同样强硬。你知道，他说亚当斯是某种隐秘的君主主义者。他是英国的傀儡。他想重新引入君主制的浮华等等。杰斐逊的竞选奏效了。所以到12月，他已经确信自己胜券在握。但有一个转折，多米尼克，你在上一集中暗示了这个转折。所以听众可能还记得，在上次选举中，亚当斯和杰斐逊是作为个人
tickets and that's how Jefferson ended up vice president to Adams. Yeah. And they are political opponents and so it's a kind of very awkward cohabitation. In the 1800 election, this isn't going to happen because both the candidates for the presidency, Adams and Jefferson are running on a kind of. joint ticket. They have selected someone who will run with them who is slated to serve as their vice president should they win the election. And the man on Jefferson's ticket to serve as vice president is a lawyer from New York who earlier in the year had shown himself such a whiz
候选人参选的，这就是杰斐逊最终成为亚当斯副总统的原因。是的。他们是政治对手，所以这是一种非常尴尬的同居。在1800年的选举中，这种情况不会发生，因为总统职位的两位候选人，亚当斯和杰斐逊，都是以某种联合竞选的方式参选。他们选择了某人与他们一起竞选，如果他们赢得选举，此人将被安排担任副总统。而杰斐逊竞选名单上担任副总统的人选，是一位来自纽约的律师，他在今年早些时候表现出了如此出色的
at electioneering that he had basically delivered the state to Jefferson. And the name of this man is Aaron Burr. Brilliant to have. him back on the show. So this is the guy who's going to go on to shoot Hamilton. Yeah. But four years before he guns down Alexander Hamilton, he very nearly guns down the presidential hopes of Thomas Jefferson. And this is because when the votes from the Electoral College are formally delivered on the 11th of February 1801, that's an absolute disaster for Jefferson's handlers because Jefferson and Burr turn out to have the same number. So it's a tie. And this was not meant to happen. Yeah, because basically, they've elected the Electoral College. And one of the people in the Electoral College, one of the
竞选能力，以至于他基本上把该州交给了杰斐逊。这个人的名字叫阿龙·伯尔。很高兴他回到节目中。所以这就是那个后来去枪杀汉密尔顿的人。是的。但在他枪杀亚历山大·汉密尔顿四年前，他差点枪杀了托马斯·杰斐逊的总统希望。这是因为当选举人团的选票在1801年2月11日正式送达时，这对杰斐逊的操盘手来说是一场绝对的灾难，因为杰斐逊和伯尔的票数竟然相同。所以这是一个平局。这本不该发生。是的，因为基本上，他们选出了选举人团。而选举人团中的一个人，其中一位
Democratic Republican electors, was meant to have cast his vote for Jefferson, but not for Burr. And forgets. Yeah, he basically, no one really knows exactly why this happened. But Jefferson and Burr end up with the same number of votes, 73, 73, instead of 73, 72, which was the plan. So it's not clear which one of them is going to be president. And as we said last time, if Burr had been almost anybody else but himself, he would have stepped aside and said, well, obviously, there's been a, something's gone wrong. And Jefferson's meant to be president. That's fine. Instead, Burr being, he's like, brilliant. I can be president now. Well, he said, he says of it, I've got, you know, he's gone into politics for fun and honor and profit. Which is very upfront. Yeah.
民主共和党选举人，本应把票投给杰斐逊，而不是伯尔。但他忘了。是的，他基本上，没人确切知道为什么会发生这种情况。但杰斐逊和伯尔最终获得了相同的票数，73票对73票，而不是计划中的73票对72票。所以不清楚他们中谁将成为总统。正如我们上次所说，如果伯尔是除了他自己以外的几乎任何人，他都会退后一步说，好吧，显然出了点问题。杰斐逊应该是总统。没关系。相反，伯尔是那种，他就像是，太棒了。我现在可以当总统了。好吧，他对此说，我，你知道，他进入政界是为了乐趣、荣誉和利润。这非常直白。是的。
So he's not going to lay down. And so the election goes to the House of Representatives. And there are now 16 states, so three new states. And each of those have an individual vote. And there is massive scope for kind of anti-Jefferson mischief here. People can see that Burr is not ideal presidential material. But at the same time, it is precisely the fact that Jefferson is so obviously brilliant and such a kind of incredibly effective political operator, which means that Hamilton and Adams and the Federalists,
所以他不会放弃。于是选举进入了众议院。现在有16个州，所以有三个新州。每个州都有一张个人选票。这里有巨大的空间进行反杰斐逊的恶作剧。人们可以看出伯尔不是理想的总统人选。但与此同时，正是杰斐逊如此明显地才华横溢，且是一位如此令人难以置信的有效政治操盘手这一事实，意味着汉密尔顿、亚当斯和联邦党人，
you know, they don't want anything to do with him. And so the federalists vote against Jefferson and in favor of Burr again and again and again. And these votes are being held in the capital, in Washington, and there are snowstorms raging outside. People have to be kind of brought in on stretches. It's incredible drama. And day after day, the ballots are tied. The day slipped by. There's no result. And then finally, on the 16th, of February, there have been 35 tied ballots. At last, the deadlock is broken and it's broken spectacularly. Jefferson wins the 36th ballot 10-4. Two states obtain. So it has always been a presumption then as now that there was a deal. I mean, it's pretty clear that there must have
你知道，他们不想和他有任何瓜葛。所以联邦党人一次又一次地投票反对杰斐逊，支持伯尔。这些投票是在首都华盛顿举行的，外面暴风雪肆虐。人们不得不被用担架抬进来。这真是令人难以置信的戏剧性。日复一日，投票结果都是平局。日子一天天过去。没有结果。最后，在2月16日，已经进行了35轮平局投票。终于，僵局被打破了，而且打破得非常壮观。杰斐逊以10比4赢得了第36轮投票。两个州弃权。所以，当时和现在一样，人们一直推测达成了一项交易。我的意思是，很明显一定有
been the details of it remain murky. But I think also it does come down to principle because at the end of the day, as you said in the last episode, even Alexander Hamilton has to acknowledge that Jefferson is the better candidate. So Hamilton said of Jefferson, there is no doubt, but that upon every virtuous and prudent calculation, Jefferson is to be preferred. He is by far not so dangerous a man and he has pretensions to character. Potensions to character. I love that. Damning with faint praise. So Thomas Jefferson becomes the third president of the United States. And it's a key moment in the history, not just of America, but of democracy more generally, because it demonstrates that a peaceful transfer of power from one party to another is possible. So it is, I think, a great moment in the history of democracy.
细节仍然模糊不清。但我认为这也归结于原则，因为归根结底，正如你在上一集中所说，即使是亚历山大·汉密尔顿也不得不承认杰斐逊是更好的候选人。所以汉密尔顿谈到杰斐逊时说：“毫无疑问，基于每一个有德行和审慎的计算，杰斐逊都应被优先考虑。他远不是一个危险的人，而且他有追求品格的志向。”追求品格的志向。我喜欢这个。用微弱的赞美来谴责。所以托马斯·杰斐逊成为了美国第三任总统。这是历史上的一个关键时刻，不仅对美国，对民主制度更广泛地来说也是如此，因为它证明了政党之间和平的权力转移是可能的。所以，我认为这是民主史上一个伟大的时刻。
And Jefferson does not set about guillotining his enemies. You know, he doesn't raise a gibbet. A gibbet, yes, in Washington. And at his inauguration, he affirms what is a kind of, I think, think fundamental principle of effective functioning democracy, that politics can't be a zero-sum game. And Jefferson at his inauguration, I mean, he kind of affirms what he describes as a sacred principle, that though the will of the majority is in all cases to prevail, that will to be rightful must be reasonable that the minority possess their equal rights, which equal law must
杰斐逊并没有开始处决他的敌人。你知道，他没有在华盛顿竖起绞刑架。绞刑架，是的。在他的就职典礼上，他肯定了某种我认为是有效运作的民主的基本原则，即政治不能是零和博弈。杰斐逊在就职典礼上，我的意思是，他肯定了他所描述的“神圣原则”，即“虽然多数人的意志在所有情况下都应占上风，但该意志要成为正当的，必须是合理的；少数人拥有平等的权利，平等的法律必须
protect and to violate would be oppression. So you can't go full in Jacobin. You know, just because you've won, you can't guillotine everybody. Yeah, the principle of pluralism, I suppose, that the other side have a legitimate interest, which must be respected. So I think that's an admirable, admirable expression of sentiment. And he manages to repair the breach in his friendship
保护这些权利，而侵犯这些权利将是压迫。”所以你不能完全变成雅各宾派。你知道，仅仅因为你赢了，你不能处决所有人。是的，多元主义原则，我想，另一方拥有必须被尊重的合法利益。所以我认为这是一种令人钦佩的、令人钦佩的情感表达。他设法修复了他与
with John Adams, though not with Abigail Adams. And even Hamilton, after Hamilton's death, he acknowledges as a worthy rival. So in his hallway of his private residence, he has a bust of himself. That's poor. Very Jefferson. but facing it, facing it, he has a bust of Hamilton.
约翰·亚当斯之间的友谊裂痕，尽管与阿比盖尔·亚当斯没有修复。甚至汉密尔顿，在汉密尔顿死后，他也承认他是一个值得尊敬的对手。所以在他私人住宅的门厅里，他有一个自己的半身像。那很糟糕。非常杰斐逊。但面对它，面对它，他有一个汉密尔顿的半身像。
And so this is conventionally treated as a gesture of respect. I mean, you could perhaps see it as a gesture of triumph. It's like putting up the head of a moose that you shot or something. I don't know, it's probably both. Do you know what, though, Bonaparte had a bust of Nelson? Yes. So I think there's a kind of element of that, isn't there? Respect towards a rival, I suppose.
所以这通常被视为一种尊重的姿态。我的意思是，你也许可以把它看作是一种胜利的姿态。这就像挂起你射杀的驼鹿的头什么的。我不知道，这可能两者兼而有之。你知道吗，波拿巴有一个纳尔逊的半身像？是的。所以我认为这其中有一种成分，不是吗？对对手的尊重，我想。
So Jefferson's president, and he goes on to serve two terms as Washington had done and as Adams had failed to do. And the longevity of his presidency combines with the death of Hamilton in that duel with Burr, effectively to destroy the federalists as a coherent force. And I think you could say
所以杰斐逊当了总统，他继续担任了两届，正如华盛顿所做的那样，而亚当斯未能做到。他总统任期的长久，加上汉密尔顿在与伯尔的决斗中死亡，有效地摧毁了联邦党人作为一股连贯力量的存在。我认为你可以说
that if aptitude for politics is to be measured by success in the winning and the keeping of power, then Jefferson is the great political genius among the founding fathers because he serves these two terms but he then is succeeded by his great ally, James Madison, and then three of the four presidents who succeed Madison in turn
如果政治能力要以赢得和保持权力的成功来衡量，那么杰斐逊就是开国元勋中伟大的政治天才，因为他担任了这两届任期，但他随后由他伟大的盟友詹姆斯·麦迪逊继任，然后继麦迪逊之后的四位总统中有三位
are also self-proclaimed Jeffersonians, and the only one who isn't is John Adams' son, John Quincy Adams. So there's a sense there of two rival political dynasties, but I don't think there's any question that Jefferson's is, I'm by far the most formidable. And in a sense, Jefferson as a model for presidents lasts right the way up to the Civil War, I think. Oh, completely.
也都是自称的杰斐逊主义者，而唯一不是的是约翰·亚当斯的儿子，约翰·昆西·亚当斯。所以那里有一种两个敌对政治王朝的感觉，但我认为毫无疑问，杰斐逊的王朝是迄今为止最强大的。在某种意义上，杰斐逊作为总统的典范一直持续到内战，我认为。哦，完全是。
He's a very, very effective figure, a dominant figure as a president. Well, the tradition of Jeffersonian democracy, the idea of small government, that the United States is ultimately a country of yeoman farmers, the tradition of the sort of the slightly nostalgic view of the South. I mean, that's all bound up with Jeffersonianism, I think. Yeah, and this reflects the fact that Jefferson, as well as obtaining power, is very good at using it. So it's Jefferson more than any other president who makes possible the emergency of the United States, not just as an Atlantic power, but as a continental power, and his most striking and celebrated achievement. And there is a case, I think, for saying it's perhaps the most
他是一位非常、非常有效的总统，一位占主导地位的总统。嗯，杰斐逊民主的传统，小政府的理念，美国最终是一个自耕农国家的理念，那种对南方略带怀旧的看法。我的意思是，我认为这一切都与杰斐逊主义联系在一起。是的，这反映了一个事实，即杰斐逊在获得权力的同时，也非常善于利用权力。所以，正是杰斐逊而不是任何其他总统，使美国不仅作为大西洋强国，而且作为大陆强国的崛起成为可能，这是他最引人注目和最著名的成就。我认为有一个理由可以说，这也许是
consequential act made by any US president, is the purchase in 1803 of Louisiana from Napoleon. And kind of typically, this is actually illegal under the Constitution. You know, it doesn't say anything about the right of the federal government to purchase foreign territory, but Jefferson goes ahead and does it anyway, because ultimately, I think when self-interest is up against ideals, Jefferson is a good enough politician to lay down his principles in favor of the end result that he wants. And you can absolutely see why he would have seized every opportunity to obtain Louisiana, because it's much, much, a block of territory is much larger than the current state. So it's about 16 times. It's basically the whole of middle America. It's the flyover states.
任何美国总统做出的最具影响力的行为，就是1803年从拿破仑手中购买路易斯安那。而且通常情况下，这在宪法下实际上是非法的。你知道，宪法中没有任何关于联邦政府购买外国领土权利的说法，但杰斐逊还是继续做了，因为归根结底，我认为当自身利益与理想发生冲突时，杰斐逊是一位足够好的政治家，为了他想要的结果而放下他的原则。你绝对可以看出他为什么要抓住每一个机会获得路易斯安那，因为它比现在的州大得多。所以它大约大16倍。它基本上是整个美国中部。它是那些“飞越州”。
I look at a map. I mean, it's not just Louisiana. It's Arkansas, Missouri, Iowa, Nebraska, Kansas, Oklahoma, much of Colorado, Wyoming, Montana. I mean, it's basically the middle third of the United States. Well, it's basically doubling the size of the United States. Yeah. When the Louisiana purchase goes through. So it adds over 800,000 square miles to the U.S. So that is an incredible achievement. But even with the Louisiana purchase, Jefferson's gaze, is fixed even further westwards. And so one year after the Louisiana purchase, he commissions an expedition to explore, not just that this new territory that the United States has overturned, but to go even further west as far as the Pacific. And this is the Lewis and Clark expedition
我看着地图。我的意思是，这不仅仅是路易斯安那。它是阿肯色州、密苏里州、爱荷华州、内布拉斯加州、堪萨斯州、俄克拉荷马州、科罗拉多州、怀俄明州、蒙大拿州的大部分地区。我的意思是，它基本上是美国中间的三分之一。好吧，当路易斯安那购地案通过时，它基本上使美国的面积翻了一番。是的。所以它为美国增加了超过80万平方英里的土地。这是一个令人难以置信的成就。但即使有了路易斯安那购地案，杰斐逊的目光也投向了更远的西方。所以，在路易斯安那购地案一年后，他委托了一次探险，不仅是为了探索美国已经获得的这片新领土，而且要走得更远，一直到太平洋。这就是刘易斯和克拉克探险队，
named after the two men who led it. And it's an, you know, it's a kind of key moment in establishing Americans' sense of what the continent is, that their state has been founded on. So in part, it's a scientific expedition. It brings back lots of new plants and flowers. And Jefferson's a great gardener. He adds lots of these to his flower beds.
以领导它的两个人命名。这是一个，你知道，这是一个建立美国人对他们国家所建立的大陆感知的关键时刻。所以，在某种程度上，这是一次科学探险。它带回了许多新的植物和花卉。杰斐逊是一位伟大的园艺家。他把许多这些植物加到了他的花坛里。
Also brings back some fossils, which I love. And Jefferson, again, keeps some of these. And in fact, Jefferson's only real disappointment is that they don't find mastodons. So these kind of prehistoric elephants that Jefferson had been hoping were roaming the grasslands of California. but they're not found. So it's a scientific expedition, but you know, Jefferson is always about power as well as about kind of intellectual exploration.
还带回了一些化石，我喜欢这个。而且杰斐逊，再次，保留了一些。事实上，杰斐逊唯一真正的失望是他们没有找到乳齿象。所以这些杰斐逊一直希望在加利福尼亚草原上漫游的史前大象。但没有找到。所以这是一次科学探险，但你知道，杰斐逊总是既关注权力，也关注某种智力探索。
So it is an expedition in large part to scout out the possibility of a westwards expansion towards the specific. And Jefferson calls this an empire of liberty. I mean, whether the Native Americans would see it in quite those terms is a moot point. But as you said, his vision is a United States populated by yeoman farmers rather than kind of, I don't know,
所以，这在很大程度上是一次为了侦察向西扩张到太平洋可能性的探险。杰斐逊称之为“自由帝国”。我的意思是，美洲原住民是否会以这种方式看待它是一个有争议的问题。但正如你所说，他的愿景是一个由自耕农居住的美国，而不是某种，我不知道，
an urban proletariat. And his feeling is that this is what will keep the US virtuous. And if the American people are to expand and keep their farms, then they need land. And if they need land, then they have to go basically go and grab California. That's the logic. So it's simultaneously virtuous and self-aggrandizing.
城市无产阶级。他的感觉是，这将保持美国的道德。如果美国人民要扩张并保留他们的农场，那么他们就需要土地。如果他们需要土地，那么他们基本上就必须去抢占加利福尼亚。这就是逻辑。所以它既是道德的，又是自我扩张的。
That's Jefferson. Yeah. Very, very Jeffersonian. And although Jefferson's sense that America's destiny is that of a commonwealth of yeoman farmers, I mean, this obviously doesn't turn out. Hamilton is right. America's future is capitalist. It is industrial.
这就是杰斐逊。是的。非常、非常杰斐逊主义。尽管杰斐逊认为美国的命运是一个自耕农的联邦，我的意思是，这显然没有实现。汉密尔顿是对的。美国的未来是资本主义的。它是工业化的。
Yeah. On the other hand, Jefferson is effectively the godfather of the notion of manifest destiny, a phrase that is coined decades later. But this sense that Americans have a God-given right to expand westwards and to claim this land, This also is part of Jefferson's legacy. And it's why in the 1930s, when the carvings of on Mount Rushmore were begun, Jefferson was chosen to be one of the four presidents represented on Mount Rushmore with Washington and Lincoln and Theodore Roosevelt. And Jefferson serves on Mount Rushmore as the symbol of American expansion. And it's an amazing thought. I remember reading a book years ago about what would imagine humans does fantasy.
是的。另一方面，杰斐逊实际上是“昭昭天命”概念的教父，这个词是几十年后才创造出来的。但这种美国人拥有上帝赋予的向西扩张并宣称这片土地的权利的感觉，这也是杰斐逊遗产的一部分。这就是为什么在20世纪30年代，当拉什莫尔山的雕刻开始时，杰斐逊被选为与华盛顿、林肯和西奥多·罗斯福一起代表在拉什莫尔山上的四位总统之一。杰斐逊在拉什莫尔山上作为美国扩张的象征。这是一个惊人的想法。我记得多年前读过一本书，关于人类会想象什么，这是幻想。
in the blink of an eye, what would remain of the workings of humanity over the course of the centuries and the millennia that follow. And apparently Mount Rushmore is the work of human art that would survive the longest. Really? The granite is so hard. It's been estimated that Jefferson's face will endure for seven million years. Oh, my word. Wow. So there's a thought. And you would say, I guess, if you're an American historian in the 20th century, that Jefferson's reputation as one of the most, not just most consequential, but admirable men in US history would be kind of similarly enduring. Because this is, you know, he's written the Declaration of Independence.
转瞬之间，几个世纪乃至几千年后，人类的文明成果还能剩下什么呢？显然，拉什莫尔山是人类艺术作品中保存时间最长的。真的吗？花岗岩太坚硬了。据估计，杰斐逊的面部雕像可以保存七百万年。天哪。哇。这真是一个值得深思的问题。我想，如果你是一位20世纪的美国历史学家，你会说，杰斐逊作为美国历史上不仅是最重要，而且是最令人钦佩的人物之一，他的声誉也会同样持久。因为，你知道，他撰写了《独立宣言》。
He's this great hero of the Enlightenment, the universal man, as Kenneth Clark called him, the godfather of the American West. And this is never better articulated than by John F. Kennedy in 1962, who hosted a dinner at the White House for all the living recipients of the Nobel Prize. And he welcomed them by saying, I think this is the most extraordinary collection of talent, of human knowledge, that has ever been gathered together at the White House, with the possible exception of when Thomas Jefferson dined alone.
他是启蒙运动的伟大英雄，是肯尼斯·克拉克所称的“全能之人”，是美国西部的教父。1962年，约翰·F·肯尼迪在白宫为所有在世的诺贝尔奖得主举办晚宴时，对这一点的阐述最为精彩。他欢迎他们时说：“我认为这是白宫有史以来聚集的最杰出的人才和人类知识的集合，当然，托马斯·杰斐逊独自用餐时除外。”
Oh, cheesy. This is the great hero on the nickel. This is the great hero on the $2 bill, which you want to get rid of. But today, Dominic, what would you say? reputation is. Well, this is the interesting thing. So since I would say certainly the 1990s, Jefferson's reputation has become a little bit. It's not exactly tarnished, but it's contested, isn't it? So to many people in America, including I would imagine a large proportion of our own
哦，太肉麻了。这就是镍币上的伟大英雄。这就是2美元纸币上的伟大英雄，而你却想废除它。但多米尼克，今天你会怎么评价他的声誉呢？嗯，这很有趣。我想说，至少从20世纪90年代开始，杰斐逊的声誉已经变得有点……不能说是被玷污了，但确实是有争议的，不是吗？所以对许多美国人来说，我想包括我们很大一部分
American listeners, he remains a great hero for all the reasons that you've described. And yet there are others, including perhaps some people who may listen to this show, who say, no, actually the way we should look at Thomas Jefferson is as the personification. of the greatest blot on America's record. In fact, to go further, he is the embodiment of America's founding sin. It's original sin that has tainted our experiment since the very first. And he's been the center, hasn't he, of what can only be described as a culture war that has raged for at least 30 years and probably is not going away anytime soon.
美国听众，他仍然是出于你所描述的所有原因而成为伟大的英雄。然而，也有其他人，包括可能正在收听这个节目的某些人，他们会说，不，实际上我们应该把托马斯·杰斐逊看作是美国历史上最大污点的化身。事实上，更进一步说，他是美国“建国之罪”的体现。正是这种原罪从一开始就玷污了我们的实验。他一直处于一场只能被描述为文化战争的中心，这场战争已经持续了至少30年，而且恐怕不会很快消失。
Yeah. Of all the founding fathers, I think he is now the most controversial. the great lightning rod for so many of the debates about American history. And so we will be looking at those when we come back after the break. Hey, this is Michael and Hannah from Gollhangers. The Rest is Science. This episode is brought to you by Cancer Research UK. What if your immune system could learn to recognize cancer cells? That's immunotherapy.
是的。在所有开国元勋中，我认为他现在是最具争议的一位。他是关于美国历史的许多辩论的巨大避雷针。所以我们将在休息后回来讨论这些问题。嘿，我是Gollhangers的迈克尔和汉娜。《剩下的就是科学》。本期节目由英国癌症研究中心赞助。如果你的免疫系统能学会识别癌细胞会怎样？这就是免疫疗法。
One type is car T-cell therapy. T-cells are your body's watchmen, and doctors can now extract these and reprogram them to spot. cancer. Car T cells, they've started showing this real promise in treating cancers of the blood like leukemia, because unlike most cancers, blood cancer cells, they float around separately, and that makes it easier for car T cells to seek them out and destroy them. And now, cancer research UK-funded scientists are designing car T cells that can tackle solid tumors, too, making them tougher so they can survive a more crowded and hostile cancer environment.
其中一种是CAR-T细胞疗法。T细胞是你身体的守卫，医生现在可以提取这些细胞并重新编程，让它们去发现癌症。CAR-T细胞在治疗白血病等血液癌症方面已经展现出了真正的希望，因为与大多数癌症不同，血癌细胞是单独漂浮的，这使得CAR-T细胞更容易找到并摧毁它们。现在，英国癌症研究中心资助的科学家们正在设计能够应对实体瘤的CAR-T细胞，使它们更强韧，从而能够在更拥挤、更恶劣的癌症环境中生存。
Now, these approaches are experimental, but they do start to show where to be. treatment might go next. And over the past 50 years, Cancer Research UK's pioneering work has helped to double cancer survival in the UK. I mean, this shows you how far research can take us. For more information about Cancer Research UK, their research, breakthroughs and how you can support them, visit cancerresearchukuk.org forward slash rest is science. This episode is brought to you by Hamilton the musical. Tom, and we think of America's founding fathers, we think of dusty portraits, face men with terrible teeth and of course unpaid tax bills, don't we? That's right, but what we don't see is the struggle, the resentment, the euphoria, the love, the rapping, all in the name of
现在，这些方法还处于实验阶段，但它们确实开始显示出治疗的未来方向。在过去的50年里，英国癌症研究中心的开创性工作帮助英国的癌症存活率翻了一番。我的意思是，这向你展示了研究能带我们走多远。欲了解更多关于英国癌症研究中心、他们的研究、突破以及你如何支持他们的信息，请访问cancerresearchuk.org/rest-is-science。本期节目由音乐剧《汉密尔顿》赞助。汤姆，当我们想到美国的开国元勋时，我们会想到尘封的肖像、面容严肃、牙齿糟糕的男人，当然还有未付的税单，不是吗？没错，但我们看不到的是斗争、怨恨、狂喜、爱、说唱，这一切都是以
American Independence 250 years ago. That's what we loved, isn't it, about Lynn Manuel Miranda's award-winning musical Hamilton, which we went to see with our team just the other day. It brought the story of those turbulent years to life beyond the walls of a museum from the room where it happened. It's an incredible depiction of the life and legacy of Alexander Hamilton, who was George Washington's right-hand man, an incredibly politically significant figure. It is an absolute cultural phenomenon and you can experience it right now at London's Victoria Palace Theatre. Book tickets today at Hamilton Musical.com forward slash London. At Volvo, safety is not a feature. It's our purpose.
250年前的美国独立为名。这就是我们喜欢林-曼努埃尔·米兰达的获奖音乐剧《汉密尔顿》的原因，不是吗？我们前几天和我们的团队一起去看了。它将那些动荡岁月的历史故事带到了博物馆围墙之外，带到了“事情发生的地方”。这是对亚历山大·汉密尔顿生平和遗产的精彩描绘，他是乔治·华盛顿的得力助手，是一位政治上极其重要的人物。这绝对是一种文化现象，你现在就可以在伦敦维多利亚宫剧院体验它。今天就在HamiltonMusical.com/London预订门票。在沃尔沃，安全不是一项功能。它是我们的宗旨。
rigorous crash testing, decades of learning from real accidents, innovations that help prevent accidents before they happen, and help protect you when they occur. Going above and beyond industry standards, a vision of zero collisions. Volvo's legacy revolves around you because safety is about helping to keep you and everyone around you safe for life. Learn more at VolvoCars.ca.caps.ca slash safety. Hello everybody. Now, as those of you who are good children will know, here in Britain, on the 21st of June, it's Father's Day. But not just here in Britain. It's also Father's Day on the 21st of June in the United States, in Canada and in the Republic of Ireland. So those are four countries that are united by dads who love to listen to the rest is history.
严格的碰撞测试、从真实事故中积累的数十年经验、在事故发生前预防事故并保护你的创新。超越行业标准，实现零碰撞的愿景。沃尔沃的传承围绕着你，因为安全是为了帮助你和你周围的每一个人终身安全。了解更多信息，请访问VolvoCars.ca/safety。大家好。现在，正如你们这些好孩子所知道的，在英国，6月21日是父亲节。但不仅仅是在英国。在美国、加拿大和爱尔兰共和国，6月21日也是父亲节。所以这四个国家都被那些喜欢收听《剩下的就是历史》的爸爸们团结在了一起。
And that is why we are offering an amazing 25% Father's Day discount on the subscription price to the rest is history club, because we are all heart. So treat the Peter the Great in your own life this Father's Day to early access to full series. You get early access, that you get that with membership. You get bonus episodes. You get ad-free listening. you get access to tickets for live shows. Basically, you get an entire host of supplementary benefits. And that, I think, is what a lot of patriarchs want, isn't it?
这就是为什么我们为“剩下的就是历史”俱乐部的订阅价格提供惊人的25%父亲节折扣，因为我们充满爱心。所以，在这个父亲节，用提前观看完整系列节目的机会来款待你生命中的“彼得大帝”吧。你可以获得提前观看权，这是会员资格的一部分。你还可以获得额外剧集。你可以享受无广告收听。你可以获得现场演出门票的购买权。基本上，你将获得一系列补充福利。我想，这就是许多家长想要的，不是吗？
It absolutely is because I think nothing says, Happy Father's Day, quite like the chance to listen to six solid hours ad-free about the First World War. Yeah, that's what most fathers want. So head to the rest ishistory.com and click on the world. gifts. And that gift, membership of our much-loved Restis History Club, will land straight in your father's inbox on Father's Day itself. So if you want to give the best Father's Day gift
绝对是，因为我认为没有什么比能连续六小时无广告收听关于第一次世界大战的内容更能表达“父亲节快乐”了。是的，这就是大多数父亲想要的。所以前往therestishistory.com并点击礼物。那份礼物，即我们备受喜爱的“剩下的就是历史”俱乐部的会员资格，将在父亲节当天直接发送到你父亲的收件箱中。所以，如果你想送出有史以来最好的父亲节礼物，
there's ever been in history, ever, and we say this as the presenters of the Restes History, you know what to do. It's well known that the man whom it delighteth the people to honour keeps and for many years past has kept as his concubine one of his own slaves. Her name is Sally. The name of her eldest son is Tom. His features are said to bear a striking, although sable, resemblance to those of the president himself. So this is a shocking story and it appeared on the 1st of September. 1802 in the Richmond recorder. And it was written, as you can obviously tell, by a Scottish emigre, a journalist called James Callender.
而且我们是以《剩下的就是历史》主持人的身份这么说的，你知道该怎么做。众所周知，那个深受人民爱戴的人，多年来一直把自己的一个奴隶当作妾室。她的名字叫萨莉。她长子的名字叫汤姆。据说他的长相与总统本人有着惊人的、尽管肤色较深（sable）的相似之处。所以这是一个令人震惊的故事，它出现在1802年9月1日的《里士满记录报》上。正如你显然能看出的那样，它是由一位名叫詹姆斯·卡伦德的苏格兰移民记者撰写的。
Now, Callender, you could argue, was very party pre-Tom, because the recorder was a Federalist paper, wasn't it? And Callender had originally been a kind of Jeffersonian attack dog, but then he'd been turned down for a job that he was hoping to get, and he had turned on Jefferson and basically become a federalist, a putturative federalist. brighter instead. So what's going on with this story? Is there just titlettle, rumemongering, or is it something more serious? Well, for a long time, it's been presented as a kind of fabricated attack on the author of the Declaration of Independence. This is the work of an embittered,
现在，你可以说卡伦德对汤姆有很强的党派偏见，因为《记录报》是一份联邦党人的报纸，不是吗？卡伦德最初是杰斐逊的“攻击犬”，但后来他申请一份工作被拒，于是他反戈一击，基本上变成了一个联邦党人，或者说是假定的联邦党人。那么这个故事到底是怎么回事？这只是流言蜚语，还是更严重的事情？嗯，长期以来，它一直被视为对《独立宣言》作者的一种捏造的攻击。这是出自一个怀恨在心、
acid-tonged hack. Right. And this was how Jefferson himself responded to it. So he, I mean, when I say responded, he never actually responded to the allegation personally. You know, as ever he played the role of philosopher above the fray. It's not worth, not going to dignify such titlettle by even engaging with it. And so he leaves it to people lower down the Jeffersonian food chain to kind of launch a
言辞刻薄的文人之手。没错。这就是杰斐逊本人的回应方式。所以，我的意思是，当我提到回应时，他从未亲自回应过这些指控。你知道，他一如既往地扮演着超然于纷争之上的哲学家的角色。不值得，我不打算通过参与这种流言蜚语来抬高它。所以他让杰斐逊阵营中地位较低的人去发起一场
campaign of defamation against Callender to cast him as a kind of miserable, wretched drunk. And actually, you know, Callender clearly did have problems with drink. And one year after he ran that story about this mysterious woman, Sally, he was seen staggering through the streets of Richmond in Virginia. And then later that evening, he was found drowned in three feet of water in the James River. Oh, this is very murky. This is very JFK. Well, so there was an inquest, a very hurried inquest, and it definitively discovered that there was no evidence of foul play.
针对卡伦德的诽谤运动，把他描绘成一个可怜、卑微的酒鬼。事实上，你知道，卡伦德显然确实有酗酒问题。在他刊登那个关于神秘女子萨莉的故事一年后，人们看到他在弗吉尼亚州里士满的街头蹒跚而行。那天晚上晚些时候，他被发现淹死在詹姆斯河三英尺深的水中。哦，这太阴暗了。这非常像肯尼迪遇刺案。嗯，所以进行了一次调查，一次非常匆忙的调查，最终发现没有证据表明存在谋杀。
Okay, well, that's a massive red flag. So, case closed, was it just kind of fabrication? And I think the answer to that is no, because calendar in that article was simply making public rumors that had been circulating among those in the know for several years and would continue to circulate long after calendar had drowned or been drowned. I mean, depending on your perspective. Here is, he's writing many, many years later after Jefferson's death, I think. So just before the outbreak of the Civil War. And it's a guy who'd known Jefferson well.
好吧，那是一个巨大的危险信号。所以，结案了，这只是某种捏造吗？我认为答案是否定的，因为卡伦德在那篇文章中只是公开了那些知情人士中流传了几年的谣言，而且在卡伦德淹死或被淹死很久之后，这些谣言仍在继续流传。我的意思是，取决于你的观点。这是他在杰斐逊死后很多年写的，我想。就在内战爆发前夕。这是一个很了解杰斐逊的人。
He would, like Jefferson, he was a Virginian planter. But this guy was an abolitionist. And so not as favorable to Jefferson as most Virginia planters tended to be. And it was a guy called John Hartwell-cock. and he wrote, all bachelors, or a large majority at least, keep as a substitute for a wife, some individual of their own slaves. In Virginia, this damnable practice prevails as much as anywhere, and probably more as Mr. Jefferson's example can be pleaded for its defense. He is taking that allegation absolutely for granted, and he's situating it in a kind of very specific cultural milieu, which are the tobacco plantations of Virginia, on which slavery, you know, it's not just common,
他像杰斐逊一样，是一位弗吉尼亚种植园主。但这个人是一位废奴主义者。所以不像大多数弗吉尼亚种植园主那样对杰斐逊有好感。他叫约翰·哈特韦尔·科克。他写道：“所有的单身汉，或者至少绝大多数，都把自己的奴隶当作妻子的替代品。在弗吉尼亚，这种该死的做法像在任何地方一样盛行，甚至可能更多，因为杰斐逊先生的榜样可以作为其辩护的理由。”他完全把那个指控当作理所当然，并将其置于一种非常具体的文化环境中，即弗吉尼亚的烟草种植园，在那里，奴隶制不仅是普遍的，
it is completely taken for granted. And Jefferson had grown up on exactly such an estate. And it's an estate that was called Shadwell after the London parish in the East End, where his mother had been christened before she came to America. So this takes us back to Jefferson's boyhood. Yes. And the context of 1750s, 1760s, Virginia. And it takes us to the heart of this whole question about Jefferson's slavery.
而且是完全被视为理所当然的。杰斐逊就是在这样一个庄园长大的。这个庄园叫沙德韦尔，是以伦敦东区的一个教区命名的，他的母亲在来到美国之前就是在那里受洗的。所以这把我们带回了杰斐逊的童年。是的。以及18世纪50年代、60年代弗吉尼亚的背景。这把我们带到了关于杰斐逊奴隶制问题的核心。
So, I mean, an obvious example of Jefferson's relationship with slavery, as a little boy, he had his own personal slave, didn't he? Who typically he calls Jupiter. Right. So a kind of classical reference there. And his father dies in 1757 when Jefferson is 14. And Jefferson inherits the slaves as well as the land. And he keeps both of them for the whole of his life. And the house that he comes to build on.
所以，杰斐逊与奴隶制关系的明显例子是，作为一个小男孩，他有自己的私人奴隶，不是吗？他通常称他为朱庇特。没错，那里有一个古典的指代。他的父亲于1757年去世，当时杰斐逊14岁。杰斐逊继承了奴隶和土地。他一生都保留着这两者。而他后来建造的房子，
the Shadwell estate is his great pride, his great joy. And he began building it in 1767 when he was 24. And it's a mansion on the summit of what Jefferson described as a steep and savage hill. So it's it's kind of 900 feet. So rises quite high. And because of this he called it Monticello, little mountain in Italian. And he loves it. He spends all his life building, rebuilding, renovating, tinkering with it. And it is a great neoclassical architectural masterpiece. It's Palladian, so deriving from the neoclassicism of in Italy, but perfectly fused with the new world. So it is, in architectural terms, it is the first great fusion of European architectural style
沙德韦尔庄园是他最大的骄傲，最大的快乐。他于1767年开始建造它，当时他24岁。这是一座位于杰斐逊所描述的“陡峭而荒凉的山丘”顶上的豪宅。所以它大约有900英尺高。因此，他用意大利语称它为蒙蒂塞洛，意为“小山”。他热爱它。他一生都在建造、重建、翻新、修补它。它是一座伟大的新古典主义建筑杰作。它是帕拉第奥式的，源自意大利的新古典主义，但与新世界完美融合。因此，在建筑术语上，它是欧洲建筑风格
with something that is recognizably American. And even Kenneth Clark in civilization when he's talking about Jefferson, I mean, he's a bit sniffy about it because Clark is kind of massive snob and a specialist in the Renaissance. But he says it's not bad. I mean, he says, you know, Jefferson's done pretty well here. And this is featured on the nickel. I think it's still there, isn't it? I think.
与某种可识别的美国风格的第一次伟大融合。甚至肯尼斯·克拉克在《文明》中谈到杰斐逊时，我的意思是，他对此有点挑剔，因为克拉克是一个巨大的势利小人，也是文艺复兴时期的专家。但他确实说这还不错。我的意思是，他说，你知道，杰斐逊在这里做得相当不错。这出现在镍币上，我想它还在那里，对吧？我想是这样。
It's one of the most celebrated American buildings of all, isn't it? But there is a dark side, right? Because it's built as a plantation house. Yes. So Clark in his documentary, which was made, I think, in 1970 or in 1969, he doesn't mention this. doesn't mention the fact that there are slaves. And this, according to calendar, so the Scottish guy who's mysteriously drowned,
它是最著名的美国建筑之一，不是吗？但它有阴暗面，对吧？因为它被建为种植园主宅邸。是的。所以克拉克在他的纪录片中，我想是1970年或1969年制作的，他没有提到这一点。没有提到有奴隶的事实。而根据卡伦德，也就是那个神秘淹死的苏格兰人的说法，
this is where this mysterious concubine, Sally, was being kept. So one of the hundreds of slaves that Jefferson owned across his various properties, so Monticello wasn't his only property. And Monticello alone, I'm just looking at it up, that the plantation was about 5,000 acres, and there were about 150 African-Americans working in slavery on those plantations.
这就是那个神秘的妾室萨莉被关押的地方。所以她是杰斐逊在他各个财产中拥有的数百名奴隶之一，所以蒙蒂塞洛并不是他唯一的财产。仅蒙蒂塞洛，我正在查阅，那个种植园大约有5000英亩，大约有150名非裔美国人在那些种植园里从事奴隶劳动。
And one of these is Sally. So to quote calendar again in his article, the African Venus is said to officiate as housekeeper at Monticello. Now this seems not to have been entirely accurate. Sally seems to have served Maria, who is Jefferson's daughter living at Monticello as her maid, and then in due course to have evolved to become kind of Jefferson's personal servant taking care of his chamber and wardrobe.
其中之一就是萨莉。所以再次引用卡伦德文章中的话，“据说这位‘非洲维纳斯’在蒙蒂塞洛担任管家。”现在这似乎并不完全准确。萨莉似乎是作为住在蒙蒂塞洛的杰斐逊女儿玛丽亚的女仆，后来逐渐演变成杰斐逊的私人仆人，负责照看他的卧室和衣橱。
So a kind of female valet. And the reason that we know this is because we have written evidence from her son, who was a slave on Jefferson's estate like his mother, Sally. And this is a guy called Madison Hemings, and he's called Madison after James Madison. So again, this kind of bizarre confluence between the high ideals, the high politics of the American Republic and the kind of squalid circumstances of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, you know, the slavery on Jefferson's estate. And Madison Hemings wrote up a history of his mother and his family more generally with the result that the details of her life and her ancestry have been preserved to a degree that is very, very unusual. Most slaves, obviously, the details of their lives have been completely lost. We know who Sally's mother was and who her grandmother was.
所以是一种女性贴身男仆。我们知道这一点的原因是我们有她儿子的书面证据，他像他的母亲萨莉一样，是杰斐逊庄园的奴隶。这个人叫麦迪逊·海明斯，他以詹姆斯·麦迪逊的名字命名为麦迪逊。所以，再次出现了这种奇怪的汇合，即美利坚共和国的高尚理想与杰斐逊庄园奴隶制那种肮脏环境之间的汇合。麦迪逊·海明斯写下了他母亲和他家庭的历史，结果是她生活和血统的细节被保存到了一个非常、非常不寻常的程度。大多数奴隶，显然，他们生活的细节已经完全丢失了。我们知道萨莉的母亲是谁，祖母是谁。
And you couldn't say that, I guess, of most slaves who, you know, lived in the earth. earlier years of the American Republic. So both Sally's grandmother and mother had been made pregnant by their white owners. And obviously, neither women as slaves would have had any right of refusal whatsoever. So by our standards, you would say they were the victims of rape. We don't know the name of Sally's grandmother. Madison Heming specifies that she was a full-blooded African. so had no white blood in her.
我想你不能对大多数生活在美利坚共和国早期的奴隶说同样的话。所以萨莉的祖母和母亲都被她们的白人主人弄怀孕了。显然，作为奴隶，这两个女人都没有任何拒绝的权利。所以按照我们的标准，你会说她们是强奸的受害者。我们不知道萨莉祖母的名字。麦迪逊·海明斯明确指出她是纯种非洲人，所以没有白人血统。
Right. And there is a obsession with blood in the American South. But he reports that the grandfather, so the owner who had forced himself on the grandmother had been an English sea captain named Hemings. So this is where the surname Hemings comes from. And they had had a daughter, Betty Hemings, and she had therefore been in the racist terminology of the time,
没错。美国南方有一种对血统的痴迷。但他报告说，祖父，也就是那个强迫自己与祖母发生关系的拥有者，是一位名叫海明斯的英国船长。所以这就是姓氏“海明斯”的由来。他们生了一个女儿，贝蒂·海明斯，因此，按照当时种族主义的术语，她是一个
a mulatto, meaning half black, half white. Yeah. Betty comes into the possession of a recently widowed planter called John Wiles, who, like, the head of Goldhanger, Tony Paster, was a Lancastrian. But unlike Tony Paster, he was a very sinister man. I'm glad you made that point. Yeah, I'm making that absolutely clear. So he's not just a planter. He's also a slave trader and a debt collector.
“穆拉托人”，意思是黑白混血。是的。贝蒂成为了一个刚丧偶的种植园主约翰·怀尔斯的财产，他像Gollhangers的负责人托尼·帕斯特一样，是兰开夏郡人。但与托尼·帕斯特不同的是，他是一个非常阴险的人。我很高兴你指出了这一点。是的，我绝对清楚地说明了这一点。所以他不仅是一个种植园主。他还是一个奴隶贩子和债务催收员。
Okay. And so that makes him a figure of dread among the planters of Virginia because, you know, huge numbers of the plantations are in debt. Yeah, of course. And so to have this guy, John Wiles turn up, I mean, it's a very, very bad sign. So we think of Washington. I mean, Washington's, you know, plantation is in debt. Yeah. Tobacco. Tobacco prices had gone into a deep decline in the 1760s, 1770s. Yeah. So this guy, Wiles, is, you know, you don't want to see him knocking at your door if you're a, a Virginia planter. And he keeps Betty as his concubine, and he fathered six children on her.
好的。这使他成为弗吉尼亚种植园主中令人恐惧的人物，因为，你知道，大量的种植园都负债累累。是的，当然。所以让这个叫约翰·怀尔斯的人出现，我的意思是，这是一个非常、非常糟糕的信号。所以我们想到华盛顿。我的意思是，华盛顿的种植园负债累累。是的。烟草。烟草价格在18世纪60年代、70年代大幅下跌。是的。所以这个叫怀尔斯的家伙，如果你是一个弗吉尼亚种植园主，你可不想看到他敲你的门。他把贝蒂当作妾室，并让她生了六个孩子。
And Sally, who's born in 1773, is the last of these children. So again, just to dwell on the race of this, because this is something incredibly important to the story, she is seven parts white to one part black, which qualifies her in the language of the time as an octaroon. So an eighth black. And yet she is just as much a slave as her mother had been, just as much a slave as her. grandmother had been. And the reason for this is because Virginian law is modelled on the law of ancient Rome, which specified that the legal status of a child is determined by that of the mother rather than the father, which in turn means that any children who are born to Betty by John Wiles will end up as John Wiles' slaves. So this includes Sally, obviously.
而1773年出生的萨莉是这些孩子中最小的一个。所以，再次强调种族问题，因为这对故事来说非常重要，她是七分白人血统，一分黑人血统，这使她在当时的语言中被称为“八分之一黑人”。然而，她和她的母亲一样是奴隶，和她的祖母一样是奴隶。原因在于弗吉尼亚法律模仿了古罗马法律，该法律规定儿童的法律地位由母亲而非父亲决定，这意味着任何贝蒂为约翰·怀尔斯所生的孩子最终都将成为约翰·怀尔斯的奴隶。所以这显然包括萨莉。
How does Sally end up at Monticello? Does she go, do they all go to Monticello? Is that how it works? So what happens is that in 1773, Wiles dies. Right. And this means that all his slaves pass into the hands of his heir. And his heir is his only surviving legitimate child, who is a very smart, clever, sassy, very, very beautiful woman called Martha. But he's known to her friends as Patty. And Patty in 1771 had married Thomas Jefferson. Ah, okay.
萨莉是怎么到蒙蒂塞洛的？她去了吗，他们都去了蒙蒂塞洛吗？是这样运作的吗？所以发生的事情是，1773年，怀尔斯去世了。没错。这意味着他所有的奴隶都传给了他的继承人。他的继承人是他唯一幸存的合法子女，一个非常聪明、伶俐、活泼、非常、非常美丽的女人，名叫玛莎。但她的朋友们称她为帕蒂。帕蒂在1771年嫁给了托马斯·杰斐逊。啊，好的。
And this means that when the Hemings family pass into Patty's possession, Ultimately, they pass into Jefferson's possession as well. So just to make clear what this means for the dynamics of Jefferson's marital household, Sally is the half-sister of Jefferson's wife, Patty. You know, she's decades younger, but she is the half-sister. Because they have the same father. They have the same father. John Wiles or whatever.
这意味着当海明斯一家成为帕蒂的财产时，最终，他们也成为了杰斐逊的财产。所以为了明确这对杰斐逊婚姻家庭的动态意味着什么，萨莉是杰斐逊妻子帕蒂的同父异母妹妹。你知道，她小了几十岁，但她是同父异母的妹妹。因为他们有同一个父亲。他们有同一个父亲。约翰·怀尔斯什么的。
Yes. And so when Jefferson and Patty come to have children, they have a succession of daughters, Sally is their art. Hmm. Okay. You know, this is, it's not just about owners and slaves. This is also a kind of family matrix as well. So how does Patty feel about the Hemings is who are the family of her father's concubine?
是的。所以当杰斐逊和帕蒂有了孩子，他们接连生了女儿，萨莉是她们的姨妈。嗯。好的。你知道，这不仅仅是关于主人和奴隶。这也是一种家庭矩阵。那么帕蒂对海明斯一家，也就是她父亲妾室的家人感觉如何？
Well, she's clearly not fond enough of them to set them free. You know, these are her half sisters. Sally's a half sister. She's not setting her free. Yeah. But what she doesn't do is break the family up and sell them on her father's. death, which she could have done. That would have been entirely within her rights. Instead, she keeps them together as a family. And when they move to Monticello, she employs them in the house,
嗯，她显然不够喜欢他们，以至于把他们释放。你知道，这些是她同父异母的妹妹。萨莉是同父异母的妹妹。她没有释放她。是的。但她没有做的是在父亲去世时拆散这个家庭并把他们卖掉，她本可以这样做。那完全在她的权利范围内。相反，她把他们作为一个家庭留在一起。当他们搬到蒙蒂塞洛时，她雇佣他们在家里工作，
so she doesn't send them out into the fields. Yeah. And that, by the standards of the time, it is a mercy. I mean, you would rather be employed as a slave in the house than, you know, out on the tobacco fields. Yes. She seems to have been quite close to Betty. So in 1782, two, she's kind of basically been worn out by childbirth. She's fallen very sick from TB. And Jefferson is distraught. He tends to her for months, but so also does Betty Hammings. And on the 6th of September, Patty can feel that her end is very close. She extracts an oath from Jefferson. She could not die happy if she thought her children were ever to have a stepmother brought in over them. And so Jefferson very solemnly promises not to remarry, and he does so in front of witnesses. And among these
所以她没有把他们送到田里去。是的。按照当时的水平，这是一种仁慈。我的意思是，你宁愿作为奴隶在家里工作，也不愿在烟草地里工作。是的。她似乎和贝蒂很亲近。所以1782年，她基本上被分娩折磨得精疲力竭。她因肺结核病得很重。杰斐逊心烦意乱。他照顾了她几个月，但贝蒂·海明斯也照顾了她。9月6日，帕蒂感觉到她的生命即将结束。她从杰斐逊那里得到了一个誓言。如果她认为她的孩子们会被带进一个继母，她就无法死而瞑目。所以杰斐逊非常庄严地承诺不再结婚，他在证人面前这样做。在这些
witnesses gathered around Patty's bed to hear this oath, Betty Hemings, but also Patty's nine-year-old half-sister, the daughter of Betty Hemings, Sally Hemings. And Patty dies the same day, and Jefferson is left completely prostrated by grief. And then two years later, he leaves for France to serve there as ambassador in succession to Franklin. And he takes his elder daughter, Martha, with him, but he leaves his younger daughter, Maria, behind. And then three years after that, in 1787, when Jefferson is still in France, he sends for Maria. And Maria is only eight years old at this point. So she clearly needs an attendant. And the person who is sent Maria as her kind of maid, nanny, whatever, is her 14-year-old aunt Sally Hemings.
聚集在帕蒂床边听这个誓言的证人中，有贝蒂·海明斯，还有帕蒂九岁的同父异母妹妹，贝蒂·海明斯的女儿，萨莉·海明斯。帕蒂当天去世，杰斐逊悲痛欲绝。两年后，他前往法国担任大使，接替富兰克林。他带走了大女儿玛莎，但把小女儿玛丽亚留在了后面。三年后，即1787年，当杰斐逊还在法国时，他派人接玛丽亚。玛丽亚当时只有八岁。所以她显然需要一个随从。被派去照顾玛丽亚的人，作为她的女仆、保姆什么的，是她14岁的姨妈萨莉·海明斯。
Let me just repeat one thing. Sally Hemings at this point is 14 years old. She is 14 years old. So first of all, they go to London where John Adams is the ambassador, the first American ambassador. Yeah. To the court of St. James. And Abigail Adams is with him. And she, so she hosts Maria and Sally and she thinks Sally is hopeless that she's an absolutely terrible kind of attendant.
让我重复一件事。萨莉·海明斯当时14岁。她14岁。所以首先，他们去了伦敦，约翰·亚当斯是大使，第一任美国大使。是的。在圣詹姆斯宫廷。阿比盖尔·亚当斯和他在一起。她接待了玛丽亚和萨莉，她认为萨莉无可救药，她是一个绝对糟糕的随从。
She's all over the place. But she assumes that Sally is kind of 17 or 18. She's also, we're told, light-colored, and so there's a description of her, very handsome with long, straight hair down her back. And she evidently bears a family resemblance to her dead half-sister, Patty, who had been Jefferson's wife. I mean. So she looks a bit like Jefferson's wife. Yeah. And she looks slightly older than she is.
她做事毛手毛脚。但她认为萨莉大约17或18岁。我们还被告知，她肤色较浅，所以有对她的描述，非常漂亮，长长的直发垂在背上。她显然与她死去的同父异母姐姐帕蒂有家族相似之处，帕蒂曾是杰斐逊的妻子。我的意思是。所以她看起来有点像杰斐逊的妻子。是的。而且她看起来比实际年龄稍大。
I mean, you know where this is going. Everyone knows where this is going. So Maria and Sally cross the channel. They go to Paris. They're with Jefferson. And by September 1789, when Jefferson is preparing for his return to America, Sally is pregnant. So by that point, she is what she's 16. So our source for what happens next derives exclusively from Madison Hemings, her son.
我的意思是，你知道这会走向何方。每个人都知道这会走向何方。所以玛丽亚和萨莉穿过海峡。他们去了巴黎。他们和杰斐逊在一起。到1789年9月，当杰斐逊准备返回美国时，萨莉怀孕了。所以到那时，她才16岁。所以我们关于接下来发生的事情的来源完全来自她的儿子麦迪逊·海明斯。
Okay. He writes up this story. And he reports that Jefferson takes for granted that he's going to be taking Sally back with him to Virginia. and that Sally, in Madison Heming's words, demurs. She's not going to go with him. She says, no, I'm not going to. And there are various reasons why she might feel able to do this. She has learned French by this point.
好的。他写下了这个故事。他报告说，杰斐逊认为他会带着萨莉和他一起回到弗吉尼亚。而萨莉，用麦迪逊·海明斯的话说，表示反对。她不打算和他一起去。她觉得能这样做有各种原因。她此时已经学会了法语。
So it's perfectly possible that she could stay in France and flourish there. She's not alone. She has her elder brother, James, who's been taken by Jefferson to Paris to be trained as a chef. As a chef. Yeah. So, you know, she could live with James. They could run a restaurant together. or something.
所以她完全有可能留在法国并在那里茁壮成长。她并不孤单。她有她的哥哥詹姆斯，他被杰斐逊带到巴黎接受厨师培训。作为一名厨师。是的。所以，你知道，她可以和詹姆斯住在一起。他们可以一起经营一家餐馆什么的。
But the key thing is that in France there are no slaves. So Sally is not legally a slave in France. She's free to do what she wants. There is no legal requirement for her to go back to America. Imagine, yeah, the shock of being told you had to go back to America, back to slavery. So she says, no, I'm not going to. The 16-year-old girl, and Jefferson is absolutely stunned. I mean, I don't think anyone has ever spoken to him like this before.
但关键是法国没有奴隶。所以萨莉在法国法律上不是奴隶。她可以自由地做她想做的事。没有法律要求她回到美国。想象一下，被告知必须回到美国，回到奴隶制，那种震惊。所以她说，不，我不打算去。那个16岁的女孩，杰斐逊绝对惊呆了。我的意思是，我不认为以前有人这样对他说话。
In the end, Sally does opt to go back. to Virginia with Jefferson. And Madison Hemings writes about this. To induce her to do so, he Jefferson promised her extraordinary privileges and made a solemn pledge that her children should be freed at the age of 21 years. You know, not just her children, his children as well, including Madison Hemings. And for Sally, you know, she's got this promise, but to go back to Virginia, she is returning to servitude.
最后，萨莉确实选择了和杰斐逊一起回到弗吉尼亚。麦迪逊·海明斯写到了这一点。“为了诱使她这样做，杰斐逊向她承诺了特殊的特权，并庄严承诺她的孩子将在21岁时获得自由。”你知道，不仅是她的孩子，还有他的孩子，包括麦迪逊·海明斯。对于萨莉来说，你知道，她得到了这个承诺，但回到弗吉尼亚，她正在回归奴役状态。
And she will formally remain a slave until the end of her. her days. Having said that, and whether this counts as rehabilitation, I don't know, but Jefferson does keep his word to her. So by the terms of his will when he dies, her children by him are emancipated. And Sally herself, for complicated legal reasons, she can't be emancipated, but she's kind of granted an informal freedom. So effectively, she does become free herself, not legally, but effectively. De facto, but de jure. Yeah, basically. And she ends up, leaving Monticello after Jefferson's death. She lives with two of her sons in Charlottesville, which is the nearest town, about two miles away.
她将在余生中正式保持奴隶身份。话虽如此，这是否算作平反，我不知道，但杰斐逊确实对她信守诺言。所以根据他去世时的遗嘱，她为他生的孩子被解放了。而萨莉本人，由于复杂的法律原因，她不能被解放，但她被给予了一种非正式的自由。所以实际上，她确实获得了自由，不是法律上的，而是事实上的。事实上的，但不是法律上的。是的，基本上。杰斐逊死后，她离开了蒙蒂塞洛。她和她的两个儿子住在夏洛茨维尔，那是最近的城镇，大约两英里远。
And she died there in 1835. She was 62, and the site of her grave is unknown. So a very, a kind of dark and largely occluded story apart from, you know, that kind of reference to it in the newspapers. There are only hints about what we know, right? In the sources, anyway, we'll come to other sources. Yeah. Just one last thing we should make clear. When Sally arrived in Paris, she was 14 years old, right?
她于1835年在那里去世。她62岁，她的墓地位置不详。所以这是一个非常黑暗且大部分被遮蔽的故事，除了报纸上那种提及之外。我们所知道的只有暗示，对吧？无论如何，在来源中，我们会谈到其他来源。是的。最后一件事我们应该明确。当萨莉到达巴黎时，她14岁，对吧？
Though you say she looked a year or two older, Jefferson was 44 at that point. So quite a sizable age gap, even by the standards of the rest is history. And so because it is a story that has dwelt in the shadows, there are kind of questions to be asked. So first of all, is Madison Hemings right? Can we trust him? was Jefferson really his father and that of Sally's other children? I mean, we can't take it for granted. You could say, well, Madison Hemings would say this.
虽然你说她看起来大一两岁，但杰斐逊当时44岁。所以即使按照《剩下的就是历史》的标准，年龄差距也相当大。而且因为它是一个生活在阴影中的故事，所以有一些问题需要问。首先，麦迪逊·海明斯是对的吗？我们可以信任他吗？杰斐逊真的是他的父亲以及萨莉其他孩子的父亲吗？我的意思是，我们不能认为这是理所当然的。你可以说，嗯，麦迪逊·海明斯会这么说。
I mean, it's much better to have Jefferson as your father than someone else. Yeah, of course. And throughout the 20th century, most biographers of Jefferson didn't believe it. So as a representative, let me quote, Dumas Malone. He was author of a six. Don't throw that away. His name is what? It's either Dumas or Dumas, whether he was named after the author of The Three Musketeers and whether the S was added, I'm not sure. I imagine it probably was. Dumas Malone.
我的意思是，有杰斐逊作为你的父亲比别人要好得多。是的，当然。在整个20世纪，大多数杰斐逊的传记作者都不相信这一点。作为代表，让我引用杜马斯·马隆的话。他是六卷本的作者。别扔掉那个。他的名字是什么？是杜马斯还是杜马斯，我不确定他是以《三个火枪手》的作者命名的，还是S是后来加上的。我想大概是吧。杜马斯·马隆。
And he wrote a six-volume biography of Jefferson. It won the Pulitzer Prize. Just for good measure, so there's no question where Dumas Malone is coming from. He was the Thomas Jefferson Foundation Professor of History at the University of Virginia, which had been founded by Thomas Jefferson. He definitely doesn't have a dog in this fight. So Malone in the fourth volume of his biography, he touches on calendar's accusations, his accusations about Jefferson's relationship with Sally.
他写了一部六卷本的杰斐逊传记。它获得了普利策奖。为了保险起见，所以毫无疑问杜马斯·马隆是从哪里来的。他是弗吉尼亚大学的托马斯·杰斐逊基金会历史教授，该大学是由托马斯·杰斐逊创立的。他绝对没有在这场争斗中偏袒任何一方。所以马隆在他的传记第四卷中，他触及了卡伦德的指控，他关于杰斐逊与萨莉关系的指控。
And he opines, they are distinctly out of character, being virtually unthinkable in a man of Jefferson's morals, standards, and habitual conduct. Well, that's so telling, isn't it, virtually unthinkable? I mean, this is a point,
他认为，它们明显与性格不符，在一个拥有杰斐逊的道德、标准和习惯行为的人身上几乎是不可想象的。嗯，这太能说明问题了，不是吗？几乎不可想象？我的意思是，这是一个观点，
1970, when Jefferson's moral stature is so great that it is, I mean, to most American historians, it probably is unthinkable that Thomas Jefferson could lower himself to this depravity. Right. So what changes? Well, the key development comes in 1999 when DNA tests prove that the father of Sally's children had been a member of the Jefferson male line. Doesn't prove that it was Thomas Jefferson, but I mean, it's very strong likelihood that it was. And then there's been very detailed research by the great scholar of the Hemings family and of the relationship of Sally Hemings to Thomas Jefferson, Annette Gordon Reed. And she did detailed analysis of the Jefferson archives, which are very copious. And she demonstrated that Jefferson had been
1970年，当杰斐逊的道德地位如此之高，以至于对大多数美国历史学家来说，托马斯·杰斐逊能降低自己到这种堕落程度可能是不可想象的。没错。那么什么改变了？嗯，关键的发展出现在1999年，当时DNA测试证明萨莉孩子的父亲是杰斐逊男性血统的成员。这并不能证明是托马斯·杰斐逊，但我的意思是，这很有可能是他。而且海明斯家族和萨莉·海明斯与托马斯·杰斐逊关系的伟大研究者安妮特·戈登-里德进行了非常详细的研究。她对杰斐逊的档案进行了详细分析，这些档案非常丰富。她证明了杰斐逊在萨莉·海明斯的每一个孩子出生前九个月都在蒙蒂塞洛。所以，再次强调，这是相当实质性的证据。2017年，在蒙蒂塞洛工作的考古学家挖掘了萨莉的房间，里面有原始的半壁炉和地板，它直接毗邻杰斐逊的卧室，所以仍然有杰斐逊学者怀疑这一点，但我会说现在历史学家的压倒性共识是，杰斐逊把萨莉·海明斯当作了他的情妇，麦迪逊·海明斯和她的其他孩子是杰斐逊的孩子，这一点已经被运营蒙蒂塞洛的托马斯·杰斐逊基金会所接受。所以，我认为这实际上已经结案了。
present at Monticello nine months before the birth of every one of Sally Hemings's children. So again, that's quite substantive evidence. And then in 2017, archaeologists working at chelo excavated Sally's room complete with original half fireplace and floors and it's directly adjacent to Jefferson's bedroom right so there are still um Jefferson scholars who who doubt it but I would say the overwhelming consensus now of historians is that um Jefferson had kept Sally Hemings as his mistress that Madison Hemings and her other children were Jefferson's children and this has been accepted by the Thomas Jefferson Foundation, which runs Monticello. So that effectively, I think, is case-proven.
在莎莉·海明斯每个孩子出生前的九个月，杰斐逊都在蒙蒂塞洛。所以这再次证明了这是相当实质性的证据。然后在2017年，在蒙蒂塞洛工作的考古学家挖掘出了莎莉的房间，里面有原始的半壁壁炉和地板，而且它紧邻杰斐逊的卧室。所以，虽然仍然有一些杰斐逊研究学者对此表示怀疑，但我认为现在历史学家的压倒性共识是，杰斐逊确实将莎莉·海明斯纳为情妇，麦迪逊·海明斯和她的其他孩子都是杰斐逊的后代。这一点已经被负责管理蒙蒂塞洛的托马斯·杰斐逊基金会所接受。因此，我认为这实际上已经是一个定论了。
So let's get into their relationship. So obviously there's so much, I mean, it's impossible to ever know the truth about anybody's relationship, I suppose, even your own. But their relationship is surely, I mean, the fact that they are, as it were, master and slave can never be separated from the reality of their relationship. No, it is obviously massively coercive. I mean, Jefferson owns Sally as property. And as you said, you know, he's in his mid-40s when they begin their affair and she's, you know, in her mid-teens. So in every way, there is a colossal power imbalance there. So I suppose the question that can't be answered, which people must be wondering, is why Sally agreed to go back with Jefferson to Virginia and to slavery.
所以让我们进入他们的关系。所以显然有这么多，我的意思是，不可能知道任何人的关系的真相，我想，即使是你自己的。但他们的关系肯定，我的意思是，他们作为主人和奴隶的事实永远不能与他们关系的现实分开。不，这显然是大规模的强制。我的意思是，杰斐逊拥有萨莉作为财产。正如你所说，你知道，当他们开始恋情时，他已经40多岁了，而她才十几岁。所以无论从哪个方面来看，那里都存在巨大的权力失衡。所以我认为人们一定想知道的那个无法回答的问题是，为什么萨莉同意和杰斐逊回到弗吉尼亚并回到奴隶制。
So was it homesickness, you know, for the place that she'd grown up in for her mother, for the rest of her family? Nervousness at starting a new life in France. I mean, maybe she'd been in France a few years, but, I mean, the big ask, perhaps. Yeah. She's still a teenager, right? So, yeah. I mean, do many 16-year-olds or whatever choose to start entirely new lives, cut off from
是思乡吗，你知道，因为她长大的地方，因为她的母亲，因为她家人的其他人？对在法国开始新生活感到紧张。我的意思是，也许她在法国待了几年，但，我的意思是，这是一个很大的要求。是的。她还是个青少年，对吧？所以，是的。我的意思是，有多少16岁左右的人选择开始全新的生活，切断与
their, I mean, we know from sports people who do that that they find it very daunting and overwhelming, me and that's when they have support around them. So you can imagine this is a big ask for her to stay in Paris, even though it means freedom. But to repeat, I mean, she's going back to a condition of servitude. Yeah, of course. I mean, of course. And I think, you know, you have to ask, and there may be people who feel that this is an entirely inappropriate question, but I think you can't avoid asking it. Does she have personal feelings for Jefferson, who is a man of immense charm and good looks and fame. I mean, he's one of the most famous men in the world. So, I mean, we can't know, but I would say some or all of those reasons probably offer a sufficient explanation.
他们的联系，我的意思是，我们从做这件事的运动员那里知道，他们发现这非常令人生畏和不知所措，即使他们周围有支持。所以你可以想象，对她来说，留在巴黎是一个很大的要求，即使这意味着自由。但重复一遍，她要回到奴役状态。是的，当然。我的意思是，当然。而且我认为，你知道，你必须问，而且可能有人觉得这是一个完全不恰当的问题，但我认为你无法避免问它。她对杰斐逊有个人感情吗，他是一个拥有巨大魅力、英俊外表和名声的男人。我的意思是，他是世界上最著名的人之一。所以，我的意思是，我们无法知道，但我会说，其中一些或全部原因可能提供了充分的解释。
As for Jefferson, I think it is easier to fathom what might have motivated him in risking so much by having this affair. I mean, it was so, he knew how damaging it would be if the full details of it came out. One one question, though, actually. You say he's risking so much and he knows how damaging it would be. The allegations do come out, thanks to this guy calendar, but they don't stop him becoming president. Plus, you made the point yourself, you know, that quite rightly, I think, that masters, slave owners, raping their slaves or sleeping with their slaves is extremely common in the American South. So in other words, if it came out, you know, people, a lot of, a lot of, So lots of people might say, huh, Jefferson's not the saint that he pretends to be,
至于杰斐逊，我认为更容易理解他为何会冒这么大的风险去维持这段婚外情。我的意思是，他非常清楚如果全部细节曝光，会造成多大的破坏。不过，我其实有一个问题。你说他冒了很大的风险，也知道这会有多大的破坏力。但这些指控确实在卡伦德的爆料下曝光了，可并没有阻止他成为总统。而且，正如你自己所指出的，我认为说得很对，在美国南方，主人或奴隶主强奸奴隶或与奴隶发生性关系是非常普遍的。换句话说，如果这件事曝光，很多人可能会说，呵，杰斐逊并不是他所标榜的那种圣人，
but they wouldn't necessarily be surprised or shocked that this had, that this had happened. And it might not be, well, as we know, it wasn't terminal for his political career. So is he risking that much? That's my question. I think he is for reasons that we will come to. Okay. I think he is risking a lot by having this affair with Sally Hemmings. I mean, we will come to that in due course.
但他们未必会因为这件事的发生而感到惊讶或震惊。而且正如我们所知，这对他的政治生涯来说并非致命。所以他真的冒了那么大的风险吗？这就是我的问题。我认为他确实冒了险，原因我们稍后会谈到。好吧。我认为他与萨莉·海明斯维持这段关系确实冒了很大的风险。我的意思是，我们稍后会谈到这一点。
Okay. But when it comes to his motivation, why might he have run this risk? I think it is because when you look at his life, it is clear that this is a man who is given to titanic and enduring erotic passions. And this, again, is something that many of his biographers in the 20th century didn't really want to acknowledge. So there is a brilliant biography of Jefferson that was published as late as 1998 by Joseph Ellis, American Sphinx. I mean, it's really, really good. But Ellis doubted the Hemings affair. and he famously wrote of Jefferson that he preferred to meet his lovers in the rarefied region of his mind rather than the physical world.
好吧。但谈到他的动机，他为什么要冒这个险呢？我认为这是因为当你审视他的一生时，很明显，这是一个沉溺于巨大而持久的情欲的人。而这一点，同样是许多20世纪的传记作者不太愿意承认的。约瑟夫·埃利斯在1998年出版了一本关于杰斐逊的精彩传记《美国斯芬克斯》。我的意思是，它真的非常非常出色。但埃利斯怀疑海明斯这段恋情的真实性，他曾有名言评价杰斐逊，称他更喜欢在思想的崇高领域而非现实世界中与爱人相会。
Oh, that's been nice for them. So, you know, in France, he has these kind of very elegant salon-based affairs. Right. But to give Ellis credit, when the DNA evidence came out, he changed his mind. You know, when the evidence changes, what do you do? You change your mind. He does. Yeah. And I think it's clear that when you look at Jefferson's great romantic passions, which kind of,
哦，这对他们来说倒是不错。所以，你知道，在法国，他有过那种非常优雅的沙龙式恋情。没错。但要给埃利斯记上一功的是，当DNA证据出现时，他改变了主意。你知道，当证据发生变化时，你会怎么做？你会改变主意。他确实改变了。是的。而且我认为很明显，当你审视杰斐逊那些伟大的浪漫激情时，它们某种程度上，
Mark the length of his life. He's definitely a man whose principles are capable of being overridden by his desires. So a case in point, his first great erotic obsession. He's 25 and he goes after his best friend's wife. Dominic, have you ever watched Love actually? I can imagine that you never have. I have seen them actually, yeah. It's the Kiran Knightley thing, right? So you remember Andrew Lincoln, who will go on to a glittering career fighting zombies. He's in love with Kiran Knightley, who's just married his best friend and Andrew Lincoln turns up with a load of cue cards. Christmas. Yeah. Christmas and plays some carols on a tape recorder and it proclaims his love. And then he walks away and Kira follows him and gives him a little kiss and then they run back. And that's the
贯穿了他的一生。他绝对是一个原则会被欲望所压倒的人。举个例子，他第一次伟大的情欲痴迷。他25岁时，去追求他最好朋友的妻子。多米尼克，你看过《真爱至上》吗？我可以想象你肯定没看过。我确实看过，是的。就是凯拉·奈特莉那段，对吧？所以你还记得安德鲁·林肯，后来在打僵尸的职业生涯中大放异彩的那位。他爱上了刚嫁给他最好朋友的凯拉·奈特莉，安德鲁·林肯拿着一堆提示卡出现了。圣诞节。是的。圣诞节，用录音机放着颂歌，表达了他的爱意。然后他走开了，凯拉跟着他给了他一个小吻，然后他们跑了回去。而这就是
end of it because Andrew Lincoln is a very decent man and obviously isn't going to pester his best friend's wife. Thomas Jefferson, however, a very different story. He pursues this poor woman for years And he's always kind of surprising her when she's getting dressed. He's slipping love letters into the cuffs of her sleeves. Does he get anywhere? No, he doesn't. Good for her. She stands firm and obviously the best friend is no longer the best friend when he finds out.
故事的结局，因为安德鲁·林肯是一个非常正派的人，显然不会去纠缠他最好朋友的妻子。然而，托马斯·杰斐逊的故事却截然不同。他追求这个可怜的女人多年，而且总是趁她穿衣服时给她惊喜。他把情书塞进她袖口的褶皱里。他成功了吗？没有，他没有。为她点赞。她立场坚定，显然，当那个好朋友发现真相后，就不再是好朋友了。
No. Yeah. There is a similar sense of kind of intense, erotic, emotional obsession in his marriage. So when his wife dies, he, you know, this is the middle of the War of Independence. Jefferson has a kind of key role. He's meant to be organizing the defenses. He chucks them all in, goes back to Montever's. Chello spends months kind of nursing her, mopping her fevered brow, all of this. And remember that
不。是的。在他的婚姻中，也有着类似那种强烈、情欲、情感上的痴迷。所以当他的妻子去世时，你知道，这正值独立战争期间。杰斐逊扮演着关键角色。他本该负责组织防御。他把这些都抛在脑后，回到蒙蒂塞洛，花了几个月的时间照顾她，为她擦拭发烧的额头，诸如此类。记住那个
oath that he'd given never to marry again. I mean, he keeps it. He clearly sees it as a sacred pledge. And I think that the, the likeliest explanation for his relationship with Sally is that she is the third and the most enduring of the three great passions of his life. And just to reiterate, she probably looks like his dead wife. Yeah. I mean, as we say, There are some very, very deep waters here. It's not unheard of for men in middle age to form these obsessive attachments to much younger women, after all. Indeed. And are we not right in saying that people described it at the French court and said she was very good looking?
他发过的誓言，永不再婚。我的意思是，他遵守了。他显然将其视为神圣的誓言。我认为他与萨莉的关系最可能的解释是，她是继他生命中另外两段伟大激情之后的第三段，也是最持久的一段。再说一遍，她可能长得像他已故的妻子。是的。我的意思是，正如我们所说，这里面水很深。毕竟，中年男子对年轻得多的女性产生痴迷的依恋，这并非闻所未闻。确实。我们说人们在法国宫廷描述她时说她非常漂亮，这没错吧？
Very handsome woman with the hair down her back and all that kind of thing. All of that. Yes, she's clearly very good looking. She's clearly very smart as well. Yeah. And very strong will. I mean, you know, she stood up to Jefferson, one of the most famous men in the world when she was a 16-year-old. I mean, she's clearly a very impressive person in her own right. But there is this
非常标致的女人，头发垂在背上之类的。所有这些。是的，她显然非常漂亮。她显然也非常聪明。是的。而且意志非常坚定。我的意思是，你知道，她在16岁时就敢于反抗杰斐逊，而当时他是世界上最著名的人之一。我的意思是，她本身显然就是一个非常令人印象深刻的人。但这里有一个
massive question. Why does he keep her as a slave? Why doesn't he just free her? And this is a question that in turn only scratches the surface of the biggest mystery of all, which you were, you were kind of alluding to earlier on. How could Jefferson, of all people, have kept not only Sally Hemings, whom he clearly loved, but some 130 people on the Monticello estate in bondage, and even more on his other estates. So yes, when Jefferson dies, he sets free his children by Sally, but not the other slaves. They are all sold on the block. Families are scattered to, you know, different parts of the south.
巨大的问题。为什么他要把她当作奴隶？为什么他不直接给她自由？这个问题反过来又触及了你之前提到的那个最大的谜团。杰斐逊这样的人，怎么可能不仅把萨莉·海明斯（他显然爱她）留在身边，还在蒙蒂塞洛庄园里奴役了大约130人，在其他庄园里还有更多人。所以是的，当杰斐逊去世时，他释放了他与萨莉所生的孩子，但没有释放其他奴隶。他们都被拍卖了。家庭被拆散，流落到南方各地。
I mean, that itself, the breaking up a family is by that being sold off is just unheartbreaking. Yeah, it's terrible. And there's a contrast there with Washington, who by the terms of his will, he wasn't able to free all his slaves because they were, you know, owned by his wife, but he laid down measures for them to be set free. Jefferson did not do this. And what makes the hypocrisy seem even more glaring. And this is why I think the story of him having Sally as his inverted commas, concubine, would have been damaging. Jefferson, in his original draft of the declaration, had famously lambasted slavery as, and I quote, a cruel war against human nature itself, violating its most sacred rights of life and liberties. And the other members of the
我的意思是，那本身，那种因为被拍卖而导致家庭破碎，简直令人心碎。是的，太可怕了。这与华盛顿形成了对比，华盛顿根据遗嘱条款，虽然无法释放他所有的奴隶，因为他们是他妻子的财产，但他制定了让他们获得自由的措施。杰斐逊没有这样做。这使得这种虚伪显得更加刺眼。这就是为什么我认为他把萨莉当作所谓的“妾”的故事会造成破坏的原因。杰斐逊在《独立宣言》的初稿中，曾有名言抨击奴隶制是“一场针对人性本身的残酷战争，侵犯了生命和自由最神圣的权利”。而其他
Congress, most of them from the South and therefore from slave-owning states, had edited these passages out. And Jefferson had been absolutely furious about this. He'd felt that this was kind of morally unconscionable. So there can be no doubting that as a young man, he had a passionate commitment to abolitionism, nor, I think, when you look at his political career, his writings, the framing of his political principles, the ideal of liberty, I think, did absolutely serve him as the great guiding light of everything that he wanted to achieve and to do. But can I just press you on this before? I know you want to move on, but just on this, his commitment to the ideal of liberty,
国会议员，他们大多来自南方，因此来自蓄奴州，删掉了这些段落。杰斐逊对此感到非常愤怒。他觉得这在道德上是不可接受的。所以毫无疑问，作为一个年轻人，他曾对废奴主义有着热情的承诺，而且我认为，当你审视他的政治生涯、他的著作、他政治原则的构建、自由的理想时，我认为，这绝对是他想要实现和做的一切的伟大指路明灯。但我能在你继续之前追问一下吗？我知道你想继续，但就这一点，他对自由理想的承诺，
it's very common in American history, certainly in the first, let's say, 100 years or 150 years or so, for people to feel that they are genuinely committed to the ideal of liberty, but they perceive it as having limits and that limit means you know it extends to white men largely but not to people beyond that does just is Jefferson one of those people no Jefferson is much more committed
在美国历史上，至少在最初的100年或150年左右，人们感到自己真诚地致力于自由理想，但他们认为这有局限性，这个局限意味着它主要延伸到白人男性，而不延伸到其他人，杰斐逊是那种人吗？不，杰斐逊更致力于
to an ideal of liberty such as I think we would understand it today okay he is a man of his time but he is at the cutting edge he is a committed abolitionist he's not just written the the Declaration of Independence he had put in huge passages saying that slavery should be abolished. Yeah.
一种我们今天所理解的自由理想。好吧，他是他那个时代的人，但他处于前沿，他是一位坚定的废奴主义者。他不仅写了《独立宣言》，还加入了大量段落，称应该废除奴隶制。是的。
So you're not giving him a pass, as it were, by saying, well, he's a product of 18th century, Virginia, so you'd expect him to be... No. Okay, fine. This is why I think it's so for admirers of Jefferson. It's so upsetting because to say he's merely a hypocrite that all along his devotion to liberty was a front, a show, isn't true. Jefferson is, you know, in his writings and in his... many of his political actions, he is committed to all kinds of ideals, and these ideals have many wellsprings. So he has a very idiosyncratic understanding of Jesus as a kind of non-divine moralist,
所以你并没有因为说他是18世纪弗吉尼亚州的产物，就对他网开一面，对吧？不。好吧，没问题。这就是为什么我认为这对杰斐逊的崇拜者来说如此令人不安，因为说他仅仅是个伪君子，说他一直以来对自由的奉献只是个幌子、一场表演，是不真实的。杰斐逊，你知道，在他的著作和他的许多政治行动中，他致力于各种理想，而这些理想有许多源泉。所以他对耶稣有一种非常独特的理解，认为他是一位非神性的道德家，
but he draws from the teachings of the Gospels a sense that all human beings should be free. Yeah. You know, he's got this kind of humanist understanding of the Gospels. He's also a committed admirer of the more radical end of the Enlightenment. So he, you know, he's read the philosophers of liberty. He's, you know, Locke, he's, he's massively anglophobic, it has to be said. But he's a great admirer of John Locke and the kind of, you know, the English philosophers of personal liberty, many of which feed into the kind of abolitionist arguments in Britain. And I think above all, he, I said he's a great classicist at the start of this show.
但他从福音书的教义中汲取了一种所有人类都应该自由的意识。是的。你知道，他有一种对福音书的人文主义理解。他也是启蒙运动激进派的坚定崇拜者。所以他读过自由哲学家的著作，比如洛克。必须说，他非常仇英。但他非常崇拜约翰·洛克和那种个人自由的英国哲学家，其中许多思想融入了英国的废奴主义论点中。而且我认为最重要的是，我在节目开始时说过他是一位伟大的古典学者。
he has a passionate devotion to ancient Greece and Rome that goes far beyond that of even the other founding fathers. And in particular, he is devoted to the great Roman historian Tacitus, whom he described as the first writer in the world without exception. And Jefferson finds in Tacitus an inspiration that is moral as well as political. And that inspiration leads him to enshrine liberty as the great principle that should guide human beings in leading a good life. So there are two books by Tacitus in particular that influence him. And the first of these is called Germania. It's a portrait of ancient Germany, which of course hadn't been conquered by the Romans. And Tacitus, or rather Jefferson's understanding of Tacitus, Germany is the womb of liberty.
他对古希腊和罗马有着超越其他开国元勋的热情奉献。特别是，他致力于伟大的罗马历史学家塔西佗，他称塔西佗为“世界上第一位作家，无一例外”。杰斐逊在塔西佗身上找到了道德和政治上的灵感。这种灵感引导他将自由奉为指导人类过上美好生活的伟大原则。塔西佗有两本书对他影响特别大。第一本叫《日耳曼尼亚》。它是对古代德国的描绘，当然，德国当时还没有被罗马征服。塔西佗，或者说杰斐逊对塔西佗的理解，认为德国是自由的摇篮。
And Tacitus has counterpointed it to the corruption and decadence of Rome under the Caesars. And so Jefferson sees the Anglo-Saxons who come from Germany, unconquered Germany, to Britain, and then the English settlers who had travelled from Britain to America as the bearers of this ancient flame of German liberty. And in 1776, Jefferson had proposed putting Hengist and Horsa, the legendary leaders of the Anglo-Saxon settlement in Britain, putting them on the reverse of the Great Seal, as the illustration of this ideal that the course of liberty is heading westwards from Germany to Britain
塔西佗将其与凯撒统治下罗马的腐败和颓废进行了对比。因此，杰斐逊将来自德国（未被征服的德国）的盎格鲁-撒克逊人视为这种古老德国自由火焰的承载者，随后是那些从英国前往美国的英国定居者。1776年，杰斐逊曾提议将亨吉斯特和霍萨（盎格鲁-撒克逊定居英国的传奇领袖）放在大印章的背面，作为这种理想的例证，即自由的进程正从德国向英国、
to America. And then the counterpoint to all this is Jefferson's portrayal of the lives of the Caesars, Tiberius and through to Nero. And this is the monarchy that obviously emerged
向美国西进。而这一切的对比是杰斐逊对凯撒们（从提比略到尼禄）生活的描绘。这就是在罗马共和国废墟中出现的君主制，
amid the rubble of the Roman Republic and it's a murderous and tyrannical as portrayed by Tacitus. And this is again a huge influence on Jefferson's politics. And it's a massive part of what fills him with dread that the American Republic will succumb to a new Caesar. And he, you know, there are various kind of potential
正如塔西佗所描绘的那样，它是残暴和专制的。这再次对杰斐逊的政治产生了巨大影响。这也是他担心美国共和国会屈服于新凯撒的重要原因。而且，你知道，在杰斐逊的恶魔学中，有各种各样的潜在
Caesars in Jefferson's demonology. And one is George the third. And Jefferson's anglophobia is founded in the sense he has of Britain as a new imperial Rome with George the third as a very improbable kind of colligula or Nero. I mean, this kind of amiable buffoon. He's absolutely not colligula. But Jefferson is completely sincere in seeing Britain as the kind of the new Rome murderous and tyrannical. And that of course is what informs his hatred
凯撒。一个是乔治三世。杰斐逊的仇英情绪建立在他将英国视为新帝国罗马的感觉之上，而乔治三世则是一个非常不可思议的卡利古拉或尼禄。我的意思是，这个可爱的笨蛋。他绝对不是卡利古拉。但杰斐逊在将英国视为那种残暴和专制的新罗马时是完全真诚的。当然，这正是他仇恨
of the Federalists and of their projects, right? Yes, completely. I mean, as insane as it may sound, did he think John Adams was going to become a new Caesar as well? Yes. Well, he sees John Adams as a potential Caesar, I think, and he definitely sees Hamilton as a new Caesar. And Hamilton,
联邦党人及其计划的原因，对吧？是的，完全正确。我的意思是，尽管听起来很疯狂，但他认为约翰·亚当斯也会成为新凯撒吗？是的。嗯，我认为他将约翰·亚当斯视为潜在的凯撒，而且他绝对将汉密尔顿视为新凯撒。而汉密尔顿，
who's clearly a massive wag, Jefferson, they're having dinner together and Jefferson is talking about his heroes and it's all, you know, bacon and Locke and Hamilton said, oh, my hero is Julius Caesar. He was the greatest man that's ever lived. Jefferson takes this completely seriously and it's confirmed in his darkest views. Does Jefferson have a great sense of humor? I don't think Jefferson had a great sense of human, no. No, I don't. But it is Jefferson's kind of great overriding ambition for the United States to avoid the fate of both ancient Rome and. and of Georgian Britain. And it's this that explains his, you know, his hostility to Britain, his sympathy with Republican France, his enthusiasm for yeoman farmers. You know, these are a kind of bulwark against the emergence of tyranny and decadence. And this drive westwards, you know, this empire of liberty. You plant an empire of liberty in the West, and that will enable America to stand proof against the corrupting effects of luxury and decadence. Part of this is obviously a little bit antiquarian, but Jefferson is not primarily antiquarian.
显然是个大话痨，杰斐逊，他们一起吃晚饭，杰斐逊在谈论他的英雄，都是培根和洛克，而汉密尔顿说，哦，我的英雄是尤利乌斯·凯撒。他是史上最伟大的人。杰斐逊完全当真了，这证实了他最黑暗的观点。杰斐逊有很强的幽默感吗？我不认为杰斐逊有很强的幽默感，没有。没有。但杰斐逊对美国有一个超越一切的伟大抱负，那就是避免古罗马和乔治亚时代英国的命运。正是这一点解释了他对英国的敌意、对共和派法国的同情、对自耕农的热情。你知道，这些是抵御暴政和颓废出现的堡垒。这种向西的驱动力，你知道，这种自由帝国。你在西部建立一个自由帝国，这将使美国能够抵御奢侈和颓废的腐蚀影响。这其中显然有一点古物研究的意味，但杰斐逊主要不是一个古物研究者。
He believes in the lessons that can be drawn from the classical past, but he does kind of blend it with the ideals of the Enlightenment to which he's also committed and to his very hard-nosed understanding of the contemporary political realities of America. And his dream essentially is a country that can serve as simultaneously in an embodiment of the best of ancient Greece and Rome that can be true. to the ideals of the Enlightenment and can also be something novel, something that the world has never seen before and therefore appropriate to a new world. And this ideal is evident, I think, not just in his record as president, but also in the place that he loved more than anywhere in
他相信可以从古典过去中汲取的教训，但他确实将其与他所致力于的启蒙运动理想，以及他对美国当代政治现实非常务实的理解融合在了一起。他的梦想本质上是一个既能体现古希腊和罗马精华，又能忠于启蒙运动理想，同时又能成为某种新颖事物（世界从未见过的事物，因此适合新世界）的国家。我认为，这种理想不仅体现在他担任总统的记录中，也体现在他比世界上任何地方都更热爱的地方。
the world. And this, of course, is Monticello. And this is a place that is classical, but it is also where he is anticipating the future of American ingenuity by experimenting with tomatoes and installing automatic double doors and inventing a kind of a revolving chair and recording meteorological data that is so meticulously kept that it's still being used by climate scientists to this day. So all of that, it's all kind of very scientific, it's all very progressive, it's all very enlightenment. But at the same time, you know, he does have this great love of the classics. And his dream, since he was a young man, is to live essentially like Cicero. And as a young man, he had filled, he had this commonplace book, he'd filled it
这就是蒙蒂塞洛。这是一个古典的地方，但也是他通过试验西红柿、安装自动双开门、发明旋转椅以及记录气象数据（记录极其细致，至今仍被气候科学家使用）来预见美国未来独创性的地方。所以所有这些，都非常科学，非常进步，非常启蒙。但与此同时，你知道，他确实对古典文学有着巨大的热爱。他从年轻时起的梦想，本质上就是像西塞罗那样生活。年轻时，他有一个摘抄本，他填满了
with quotes illustrating what Cicero had called dignified leisure. And Cicero enjoys this dignified leisure on his country estate. But you can't have a country estate if you're a Roman grandee without slaves. And as it turns out, Norcan Jefferson. Because to free his slave, would have destroyed the idyll that he had created for himself at Monticello. And this isn't just because he would lose the labour that the slaves provided, but because Jefferson, like so many of the tobacco farmers in Virginia, is massively in debt. And he needs the slaves as collateral against this debt.
引用西塞罗所说的“尊严的闲暇”的语录。西塞罗在他的乡村庄园里享受这种尊严的闲暇。但如果你是一个罗马权贵，没有奴隶，你就不能拥有乡村庄园。事实证明，杰斐逊也不能。因为释放他的奴隶会摧毁他在蒙蒂塞洛为自己创造的田园诗。这不仅是因为他会失去奴隶提供的劳动力，还因为杰斐逊像弗吉尼亚州的许多烟草种植园主一样，背负着巨额债务。他需要奴隶作为抵押品来偿还这笔债务。
And remember that his father-in-law had been a debt collector. And so Jefferson knows better than anyone what financial ruin might. might mean, you know, he will lose everything. And I think that ultimately Monticello is dearer to him than Sally, dearer to him than his ideals of liberty, dearer than, you know, his reputation even. So when he was in France, he'd visited Niem. And he'd gazed at an incredibly well-preserved Roman temple,
记住，他的岳父曾是一名收债员。所以杰斐逊比任何人都清楚财务破产意味着什么，你知道，他会失去一切。我认为最终蒙蒂塞洛比萨莉更让他珍视，比他的自由理想更让他珍视，甚至比他的名声更让他珍视。所以当他在法国时，他曾访问尼姆。他凝视着一座保存极其完好的罗马神庙，
great kind of gem of Roman architecture. And he wrote in a letter that he'd gazed at it like a lover at his mistress. And perhaps I, you know, at the end of the day, he loved Monticello more even than Sally, than his wife, than his best friend's wife, more than his principles, more even than how posterity would judge him. To the extent that I can explain this, you know, the paradox that is Thomas Jefferson, this I think is the explanation. You know, he is that the president of the United States.
罗马建筑的伟大瑰宝。他在一封信中写道，他凝视它就像情人凝视情妇一样。也许，你知道，归根结底，他爱蒙蒂塞洛甚至超过了萨莉，超过了他的妻子，超过了他最好朋友的妻子，超过了他的原则，甚至超过了后人会如何评价他。在某种程度上，我可以解释这一点，你知道，托马斯·杰斐逊这个悖论，我认为这就是解释。你知道，他是美国总统，
States who articulated the principles of America more boldly and more stirringly and more inspirationally than any other but I think for that reason he is also the United States president who came to betray them the most grievously he knew what he was doing right you know we joke and say Thomas Jefferson who's you know history's great monster he wasn't a monster he was a man of genuine principle but it's for that reason that his portrayal of those principles are all the more shameful, I think. You're right, yeah, because you're sort of distinguishing.
他比任何人都更勇敢、更激动人心、更具启发性地阐述了美国的原则，但我认为正因如此，他也是最严重背叛这些原则的美国总统。他知道自己在做什么，对吧？你知道，我们开玩笑说托马斯·杰斐逊是历史上伟大的怪物，他不是怪物，他是一个有真正原则的人，但正因如此，他对自己原则的背叛才显得更加可耻，我认为。你是对的，是的，因为你是在进行某种区分。
I mean, there's a difference between somebody who basically has been bred in the world of the 18th century. Right. Cannot think themselves outside it. Doesn't question the established practices at the time. And therefore, you know, owns slaves, buys and sells slaves, and it's completely implicated in what we would now regard as a horrendous institution. And you're effectively saying this is somebody who basically thinks it's wrong.
我的意思是，一个基本上是在18世纪世界中成长起来的人，与其他人是有区别的。没错。无法跳出那个时代去思考。不质疑当时既定的做法。因此，你知道，拥有奴隶，买卖奴隶，完全卷入了我们现在所认为的恐怖制度中。而你实际上是在说，这是一个基本上认为这是错误的人。
He knows it's wrong. To the depths of his heart in his marrow. Knows it's wrong, but his own pastoral, classical fantasy world, as it were, means more to him than doing what he believes to be right. And presumably he told himself, the slaves are much better living with me on my plantation and working for me. I think he probably did tell himself that, but I don't think that's a justification that he would have accepted. Right.
他知道这是错的。深入骨髓地知道这是错的，但他自己的田园古典幻想世界对他来说比做他认为正确的事更重要。大概他告诉自己，奴隶们在我的种植园里和我一起生活、为我工作要好得多。我想他可能确实这样告诉过自己，但我不认为这是他会接受的辩解。没错。
You know, and that's why I think if he were alive now, he would accept the force of the arguments made by his critics. He would be on their side in his gut. Yeah. In saying that he did wrong. And I think that if the definition of a tragedy is that, you know, someone who is destroyed by their own best qualities,
你知道，这就是为什么我认为如果他现在还活着，他会接受批评者提出的论点。他会在内心深处站在他们这一边。是的。承认他做错了。而且我认为，如果悲剧的定义是，你知道，一个人被自己最好的品质所毁灭，
Jefferson is the great tragic president. Because the very thing that people admire that millions of tourists go to sea every year, which is Monticello, you're arguing, is the thing that basically subverts his moral compass. Monticello is the architectural embodiment of all Jefferson's ideals. You know, his love of ancient Greece and Rome, his commitment to enlightenment principles, his investment in all the kind of incredible ingenuity that will be character. of America over the course of her existence. And that's why Americans instinctively feel this. It's why it's one of the great kind of monuments, great centers of pilgrimage in the United States. But ultimately, that house could not have functioned without slaves. And had Jefferson sold his slaves, he would have lost the house, he would have lost the estate, he would have been ruined.
杰斐逊就是伟大的悲剧总统。因为人们所钦佩的、每年有数百万游客前往参观的东西，也就是蒙蒂塞洛，你认为，正是那个基本上颠覆了他道德指南针的东西。蒙蒂塞洛是杰斐逊所有理想的建筑体现。你知道，他对古希腊和罗马的热爱，他对启蒙运动原则的承诺，他对所有那些将成为美国存在过程中特征的不可思议的独创性的投入。这就是为什么美国人本能地感受到这一点。这就是为什么它是美国伟大的纪念碑之一，伟大的朝圣中心之一。但归根结底，那座房子如果没有奴隶是不可能运作的。如果杰斐逊卖掉了他的奴隶，他就会失去房子，失去庄园，他就会破产。
Yeah. And he couldn't bring himself to do it. He couldn't bear to do it. Okay. Well, fascinating story, brilliantly told. Thank you, Tom. So that brings to an end of our founding father's series, but Jefferson himself will be delighted to hear because he loved Greece and Rome, that we're actually returning next week with a proper classical subject. Because of course, Christopher Nolan's film, The Odyssey, is about to hit the cinemas. And we will be venturing back to Homeric Greece, to the world of gods and monsters to dig deep into the Odyssey and tease out what it's all about and what it means. And those episodes will be out for rest of, History Club members on Monday.
是的。而他无法强迫自己这样做。他无法忍受这样做。好吧。嗯，引人入胜的故事，讲述得非常精彩。谢谢你，汤姆。所以这结束了我们的开国元勋系列，但杰斐逊本人会很高兴听到，因为他热爱希腊和罗马，我们下周实际上将回归一个真正的古典主题。因为当然，克里斯托弗·诺兰的电影《奥德赛》即将上映。我们将冒险回到荷马时代的希腊，回到众神和怪物的世界，深入挖掘《奥德赛》，剖析它的全部内容及其意义。这些剧集将于周一为历史俱乐部成员发布。
So if you want to hear both episodes straight away, go to the rest is history.com and sign up. And Tom, I believe there's all kinds of other benefits, aren't there? Oh, massive supplementary benefits. Supplementary benefits, I think is the technical term. Incredible supplementary benefits. You only get them if you sign up at the website. And of course, there is our super sawaway newsletter every Friday,
所以如果你想立刻听到这两集，请前往therestishistory.com并注册。汤姆，我相信还有各种其他福利，对吧？哦，巨大的补充福利。补充福利，我认为这是专业术语。不可思议的补充福利。你只有在网站上注册才能获得。当然，还有我们每周五的超级通讯，
which will have loads more about all of this kind of stuff. So I advise people to sign up for the newsletter. And yeah, thank you very much, Tom. And we will return next week with The Odyssey. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Hi, everybody. It's Dominic here from The Restis History. I just wanted to let you all know that on our sister podcast, The Book Club, we have just released an episode digging deep into George R.R. Martins,
里面会有更多关于所有这些东西的内容。所以我建议人们注册通讯。是的，非常感谢你，汤姆。我们下周将带着《奥德赛》回归。再见。再见。大家好。我是来自《历史的其余部分》的多米尼克。我只是想让你们都知道，在我们的姐妹播客《读书俱乐部》中，我们刚刚发布了一集深入探讨乔治·R·R·马丁的
a Game of Thrones. The first book in his Song of Ice and Fire sequence. We go deep into the history behind Game of Thrones. So we go into the Wars of the Roses, Hadrian's Wall. We talk about the influence of Jera Tolkien and in comparisons with the the Lord of the Rings. We talk about the violence of the books. But Tabby, we also talk, don't we, about George R.R. Martin's apparent stagnation and whether he's actually ever going to finish the books. We investigate why it is that he has battled to finish them at all and whether he will ever be able to. If you want to hear lots more about the history behind some of the greatest novels of all time,
《权力的游戏》。他《冰与火之歌》系列的第一本书。我们深入探讨了《权力的游戏》背后的历史。所以我们谈到了玫瑰战争、哈德良长城。我们谈到了J·R·R·托尔金的影响以及与《指环王》的比较。我们谈到了书中的暴力。但塔比，我们也谈到了，不是吗，关于乔治·R·R·马丁明显的停滞，以及他是否真的会完成这些书。我们调查了他为什么在完成它们方面如此挣扎，以及他是否还能完成。如果你想听到更多关于有史以来最伟大的小说背后的历史，
fear not. Because coming up on the book club, we have The Leopard by Giuseppe Tomasi de Lampedusa, which is all about Italian unification. We talk about Circe, where we delve into a particular part of the Odyssey. And then after that, we are doing the 39 steps, which is, I know Dominic, you chose and you love. Please join us at the book club. It's loads of fun,
别担心。因为在读书俱乐部即将推出的节目中，我们有朱塞佩·托马西·迪·兰佩杜萨的《豹》，它讲述的是意大利统一。我们谈到了《喀耳刻》，我们深入探讨了《奥德赛》的特定部分。在那之后，我们将做《三十九级台阶》，我知道多米尼克，这是你选择的，你很喜欢。请加入我们的读书俱乐部。这非常有趣，
and you will never find a better way to spend your life. Bye-bye. Bye. Dominic, since it's the summer, I've obviously been thinking a lot about cricket. However, I am aware that the World Cup is on as well. And so occasionally, football intrudes on my mind as well. And so I've been thinking about what my historical dream football teams would be. And who would be in your historical dream
你永远找不到比这更好的生活方式了。再见。再见。多米尼克，既然是夏天，我显然一直在想板球。然而，我也意识到世界杯也在进行中。所以足球偶尔也会闯入我的脑海。所以我一直在想我的历史梦之队会是什么样子。谁会出现在你的历史梦之队中？
team? I've numbered it down to four what I think would be the classics. And they are, of course, the Aztecs, the Royal Navy. We've got to have the Royal Navy. Ostrohungary. And of course, ancient Rome. I mean, it's an amazing coincidence. the rest is history have just launched football shirts for those very teams. So if there are people out there who want to know what Quauteimok would have worn during the seat of Tenochtitlan or Nelson, this is your chance to find out. And how would one, put it bluntly, me, how would I get my hands on one, two, three, or perhaps all of these bespoke kits? You would want to head as quickly as possible to the rest is history.com and you go to the merch tab, then you would be able to pre-order one of these fantastic limited edition shirts.
我把它缩小到了四个我认为是经典的选择。它们当然是阿兹特克人、皇家海军。我们必须有皇家海军。奥匈帝国。当然，还有古罗马。我的意思是，这是一个惊人的巧合。《历史的其余部分》刚刚为这些球队推出了足球衫。所以如果外面有人想知道夸特莫克在特诺奇蒂特兰围城战中会穿什么，或者纳尔逊会穿什么，这是你们发现的机会。那么，直截了当地说，我，我该如何弄到一件、两件、三件，或者也许是所有这些定制球衣呢？你会想尽快前往therestishistory.com，然后去商品标签页，这样你就可以预订这些精彩的限量版球衣之一。
Would there be a way of personalising these shirts? I'm going to make you so happy now because actually there would. Each shirt can be personalized with a choice of historical figures, the big names from that particular team. So, for example, the Royal Navy, you can go over. for Horatio Nelson or Emma Hamilton. You can go for Franz Ferdinand or Sophie for the Austro-Hungarian Empire. For the Aztecs, you can go for Quahtamok, Montezuma or Malinche.
有没有办法个性化这些球衣？我现在要让你非常高兴，因为实际上是有的。每件球衣都可以用该特定球队的历史人物（大人物）的选择进行个性化。例如，皇家海军，你可以选择霍雷肖·纳尔逊或艾玛·汉密尔顿。对于奥匈帝国，你可以选择弗朗茨·斐迪南或索菲。对于阿兹特克人，你可以选择夸特莫克、蒙特祖马或马林切。
Okay, these sound absolutely brilliant. The perfect way for our beloved listeners to celebrate the World Cup. And I will certainly be heading to the website and clicking on the merch page on restishistory.com. I simply cannot wait. Hello there. It's Al Murray here and James Holland there. hosts of the Second World War Pod. We have ways of making you talk. Al and I have been on The Rest Is History a few times now, talking all things World War II with Tom and Dominic. If you've enjoyed their recent topics on 20th century history, then we have good news for you.
好吧，这些听起来绝对棒极了。这是我们敬爱的听众庆祝世界杯的完美方式。我肯定会前往网站并点击restishistory.com上的商品页面。我简直等不及了。你好。我是阿尔·默里，那是詹姆斯·霍兰德。第二次世界大战播客的主持人。我们有办法让你开口。阿尔和我现在已经上过几次《历史的其余部分》，和汤姆与多米尼克谈论二战的所有事情。如果你喜欢他们最近关于20世纪历史的话题，那么我们有好消息告诉你。
Yes, that's right, Jim. We have our own show, all about the fascinating history of World War II. Every Tuesday and Thursday, WW2 Pod, we have ways of making you talk, discusses the fascinating people, amazing innovations. and terrible tragedies of this most pivotal period in human history. Yeah, and the bottom line is, other history has absolutely nothing on this. This past year alone, we've done series on visionary US presidents like FDR and Truman, HMS Hood v Bismarck, and Japan's Road to War. We've also explored daring night raids behind enemy lines like Brunovol and the nerve-wracking Atlantic convoys.
是的，没错，吉姆。我们有自己的节目，全是关于二战迷人的历史。每周二和周四，二战播客《我们有办法让你开口》都会讨论人类历史上这个最关键时期迷人的人物、惊人的创新和可怕的悲剧。是的，底线是，其他历史与此相比完全不算什么。仅在过去一年里，我们就制作了关于富有远见的美国总统（如罗斯福和杜鲁门）、胡德号对阵俾斯麦号以及日本战争之路的系列节目。我们还探索了像布鲁诺瓦尔这样深入敌后的勇敢夜袭，以及令人神经紧张的大西洋护航队。
And right now, we're doing the truly Titanic Operation Barbarossa, the Nazi German invasion of the Soviet Union in the South. summer of 1941. So now is a great time to subscribe and get into the action. Search, We Have Ways, wherever you get your podcasts. That's we have ways wherever you get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
现在，我们正在做真正泰坦尼克号式的巴巴罗萨行动，即1941年夏天纳粹德国对苏联的入侵。所以现在是订阅并参与行动的好时机。在任何你获取播客的地方搜索“We Have Ways”。这就是在任何你获取播客的地方搜索“We Have Ways”。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。